Salaida!
So Leute, da bin ich, ne ich hab mir noch keine Emotes machen lassen.
Ich hab mir noch gar nichts machen lassen, ich hab keine Subscriber-Batch, ich hab keine
Emotes und das Schlimme ist, warte mal, Kabi muss mal kurz die Klappe halten, das Schlimme
ist, ich check auch die Einstellungen nicht, wo ich was hoch lade, ich muss mir das echt
in Ruhe nochmal angucken.
Ich brauch, ich brauch einen guten, oh jetzt kommen die, jetzt kommen die, die Subs, ja
danke Leute.
Ähm, es gibt doch jetzt, wie heißt es, Fiverr oder Fiverr, da kann man sich irgendwelche
Leute mieten, die für ein Emotes machen, ne aber ich werde mir auf Twitter mal, ich
werde mal auf Twitter ein bisschen gucken, wer das so ist und wie gesagt, ich will auch,
ich will auch nicht, dass irgendwie einer für mich Zeugs umsonst macht, aber das sollte
dementsprechend aber halt auch auf was tauchen, auf was taugen, warum ist so ein PP-Gabbot
nicht an?
Jaja, continue, Fiverr, heißt es Fiverr, heißt es Fiverr, ich weiß es nicht, Fiverr,
also ich hab keine Ahnung, was wir heute machen, ich bin jetzt einfach nochmal on gekommen,
gekommen, weil ich gerade gesehen habe, dass die Twitch-Partnerbewerbung angenommen wurde. Aber erst mal die ganzen Grams hier starten.
Vielleicht vom letzten Mal noch ein paar Fragen auf haben.
Ich müsste
zumindest Sub-Benachrichtigungen und so Gedöns schon eingeschaltet haben, hoffe ich mal.
Nice, ja doch, ist eingeschaltet. Ich sehe es, ShircoSky.
Ah, ist doch cool. Ich bin echt froh, dass das geklappt hat. Danke für die ganzen Subs. Übrigens auch danke für die ganzen Subs schon, die es gegeben hat, bevor ich überhaupt online gekommen bin mit dem Stream.
Noch mehr, jetzt geht es aber ab.
KS. Twitch Prime. Stimmt, jetzt kann ich ja den Twitch-Cast-Corian auch danken bei dir für den Sub. Jetzt kann ich ja den Twitch Prime-Sellout machen, Leute.
Habt ihr schon euren Amazon-Account mit Twitch verknüpft?
Ja, ich, normalerweise hätte ich gesagt, dann könnt ihr euch Twitch kostenlos angucken und einen Streamer eurer Wahl kostenlos abonnieren im Monat.
Allerdings hat sich Amazon letztes Jahr überlegt, es gibt keine Werbung, äh, es gibt wieder Werbung, auch für Prime, Leute.
Das heißt, aktuell bringt das eigentlich nur, ich glaube, irgendwelche kostenlose Drops, die ich nicht verwende, und man kann kostenlos den Streamer seiner Wahl unterstützen.
Das ist auch das Einzige, was ich persönlich mit meiner Twitch-Prime-Geschichte mache.
Ähm, die ganzen, ich weiß nicht, wie es bei euch ist, aber die ganzen anderen Twitch-Prime-Sachen nehme ich eigentlich gar nicht in Anspruch.
Ich hab zig, zig hunderte Einträge hier, dass ich irgendwelche Loot-Geschichten unlockt habe, dass ich, ich glaube, ich hab bisher noch nicht eine Sache eingelöst, aber so kann ja jeder machen, wie er will, ne?
Ähm, ja, und jetzt an der Stelle mal gesagt, ich bin froh über jeden Sub, aber er sollte sich natürlich nach wie vor keiner irgendwie gezwungen fühlen.
Ich komm auch ohne Twitch-Subs über die Runden, ja, kein Problem, aber ich find's natürlich schön, und was ich, was ich fast nur schöner finde ist,
und das muss ich jetzt an der Stelle auch mal loswerden, weil jetzt, wo ich Partner bin, kann ich den richtigen Sellout starten.
Ähm, dass so viele Leute immer bei den Streams am Start sind, ähm, das ist ja schon ein ziemliches, wen haben wir jetzt?
Philipp Hü, danke für den Sub, ähm, wo war ich gerade stehen geblieben?
Genau, ich wollte die übliche Subscriber-Einschreiben-Action loslassen, und zwar, ich find's wirklich schön, dass immer so viele Leute am Start sind, weil ich weiß, dass das hier an sich ein ziemliches Nischenthema ist, ja?
Vor allem auf Twitch, so, Streams, die sich, oder generell, es ist auch auf YouTube so, Videos und, und Content, der sich wirklich mit Technik ein bisschen tiefer greift und beschäftigt, ist rar, gibt's nicht so viel.
Es gibt ganz viele Technik-Channels, die sich Technik-Channels nennen, und die machen dann im Endeffekt sowas wie Smartphone-Reviews, oder zeigen vielleicht mal das Einrichten von irgendeinem, von irgendeinem WLAN-Repeater-Router, oder hast du nicht gesehen?
Aber, was wir hier machen, ist ja schon, meistens zumindest, ne Runde Advanster, und, deswegen find ich das gerade so schön, dass so viele Leute am Start sind, und was ich auch cool finde, dass hier doch der Anteil an Leuten, die sich dafür interessieren, und vor allem auch, die sich in verschiedenen Themenbereichen auskennen, kommt mir zumindest relativ hoch vor.
Das find ich sehr nice, ja nice, äh, danke SeriousMax, aber das ist wirklich cool, Morgengemüse, Dankeschön für den Sub, Twitch Prime, Matt, kann ich dir Recht geben, ähm, ich find's auch ein bisschen merkwürdig, wenn man sagt, ich bin Technik, die sagen ja nicht, ich bin Technik-Experte, aber ich finde, ein richtiger Technik-Channel,
ich weiß nicht, ob man das Technik nennen kann, wenn man sich zum größten Teil mit Swat vor uns beschäftigt, das ist jetzt nichts gegen die Channels und die Leute an sich, da gibt's auch wirklich nette Leute, aber, mit Technik hat's aus meiner Sicht nicht so viel zu tun.
Endlich kann man suppen, ja, seit 5 Minuten.
Demnächst gibt's übrigens auch, ich muss mir echt Gedanken machen, was ich als Subscriber-Batch mache, vielleicht machen wir ein paar Keks-Krümmel oder irgendwie sowas, ich hab nur wirklich keine Ahnung, also wir müssen uns mal aufschreiben, was wir noch machen müssen, also, wichtig, was müssen wir machen, wir brauchen eine Subscriber-Batch, ich kann die gar nicht mehr schreiben, Subscriber, hat man,
hat man, hat man einen Lehrer bei mir an der Schule, kann ich mich noch dran erinnern, habe ich an der Berufsschule, übelster, übelster Fail, hat er mal irgendwas vorgelesen und auf einmal hat er irgendwas die ganze Zeit erzählt von Subscriberin, bis ich dann irgendwann, was meint er eigentlich, meint er abonnieren, und dann hat er gesagt, ja, ich hab noch nie jemand gehört, der ernsthaft Subscriber mit Subscriberin übersetzt hat, und ich hab gedacht, es war so,
aber der war, der war seiner Zeit voraus, der,
Dis-Abo,
gibt's nen Subcounter, ähm, ich würde selbst keine gucken, wie viele Subs ich hab,
ich hab keine Ahnung, wo ich das überhaupt nachgucken kann,
ich hab, ich muss, ich, wie gesagt, ich hab dieses, dieses Twitch-Onboarding,
ich hab mich vor 5 Minuten oder 10 Minuten fertiggemacht, ich hab wirklich absolut keinen blassen Schimmer,
Streamlabs, ja, bestimmt, allerdings würde ich gerne, ja, ich war in Frankfurt auf der Hochschule,
allerdings würde ich selbst gerne mal erst mal checken, wo ich das überhaupt sehe,
das seh ich garantiert irgendwo in den Account-Settings, aber ich hab keine Ahnung,
dann lass uns zusammen rausfinden, das geht nicht, da müssen sich die Account-Settings hier aufm,
aufm Stream aufmachen, und da sieht man auch noch mehr von, äh, Adresse zu Kontonummer und zu,
Adre-, und, und, und, und Name, Adress, all mögliche, das geht nicht,
als wären sich nur die Subs gegiftet, ein nicer Schachzug,
KioKoll, danke für den Sub,
Casino Capitalist, danke für den Sub, jetzt geht's aber ab hier, meine Güte,
ich hab jetzt ja schon innerhalb von, noch mehr, ach du Scheiße, ich hab jetzt ja schon,
keine Ahnung, Laupertin auch bei dir, danke für den Sub, ähm, ich hab jetzt innerhalb von 10
Minuten oder so 15 Subs oder was gekriegt, easy, da fällt mir nix anderes ein, da gibt's,
Flixcoder auch am Start, dankeschön, ähm, also lass uns überlegen, was wir brauchen,
ich brauch ne Subscriber-Batch, ich brauch, ich, ich weiß gar nicht,
wie viele Emotes man zum Start kriegt, wahrscheinlich eins oder so, oder fünf,
oder ich weiß gar nicht, muss ich gar nicht gucken, Ray, das ist ne gute Frage,
da sag ich gleich was zu, ähm, da sag ich gleich was zu, Technik-Channels auf YouTube,
ich find, gibt ein paar, gibt ein paar ganz gute, so Abseits von Linux Tech-Tipps,
man sagen muss, Linux Tech-Tipps, ich würd den schon als Technik-Channel durchgehen lassen,
allerdings ist das eigentlich hauptsächlich ein Entertainment-Channel, ich mein, ganz ehrlich,
ähm, wer find das nicht lustig, wenn sie sich in den Intel-Server hinstellen und versuchen mit
ihren Füßen die CPUs anzudrücken, dass der Server startet, aber, ähm, wirklich mit Technik
hat das nicht viel zu tun, äh, äh, äh, Linux Technik, nicht Linux, Alter.
Was passiert eigentlich, wenn einer jetzt 100 Subs giften würde, wenn nur 80 Leute im Chat sind?
Naja, in Anbelang der Tatsache, dass du dir die Subs irgendwelchen Leuten giften musst,
funktioniert das nur so lange, wie Leute da sind.
Es sei nur Gift des Subs, Leute, die nicht da sind. Hallo, Quallog. Also, Emoji brauchen wir,
da muss ich mir unbedingt, äh, einen Artist suchen, einen, der das machen kann, wie ich mir das
vorstelle, bzw. der vielleicht auch ein paar Ideen hat, wie man's machen könnte, weil ich da bei
solchen kreativen Sachen, was künstlerische Sachen angeht, nicht so, nicht so das Händchen für hab.
Was bringt es, einen Sub gekiftet zu bekommen? Du bist ganz normaler Sub. Das ist ein richtiger
Sub, äh, nur, dass du ihn nicht selbst bezahlen musst. Also, optimal, um die Grills zu beeindrucken.
So sieht's aus.
Leider kann man seinen Prime-Sub, glaub ich, nicht giften. Macht die Ecke von einem Keks,
der, macht die Ecke von dem Keks, die fehlt als Sub-Icon. Das ist ne richtig coole Idee.
Gibt's hier im Chat eigentlich Grills? Es gibt generell im Internet keine Grills.
Das ist, das ist nur Gerücht. Wupplotzmonka-Emote. Ja, da müssen wir mal gucken. Ich hab, wie gesagt,
ich hab echt keine Ahnung, wie das funktioniert. Also, wir brauchen Emotes. Wir brauchen noch die
neuen FFZ-Emotes. Geht eigentlich POC mittlerweile. Der Rüpel, danke für den Sub. Ähm, können wir
mal ausprobieren, ob POC als Emote mittlerweile funktioniert. Ich hab's vorhin FFZ-mäßig eingetragen.
Ja, funktioniert. Ja, sehr schön. Ähm, jetzt mal so außer der Reihe. Normalerweise erzähl ich ja
nicht so Zeug, aber, aber zur Feier des Tages, weil gerade jemand gefragt hat, ob Grills in dem Chat
sind. Ähm, hotte Grills natürlich. Ähm, dachte ich mir, ich könnte mal eine, eine Real-Life Story zum
Besten geben, was damit was zu tun hat. Und online Grills, in Kombination. Ist ja nicht so oft Thema
bei mir. Und es könnte sogar sein, dass ich das schon mal erzählt hab, weil das war so ein, ähm,
einschneidendes Erlebnis, wo ich die Welt nicht mehr verstanden hab. Wo fang ich denn jetzt am besten an?
Ähm, also ich bin mittlerweile, ich wusste, ich wusste vielleicht ein bisschen weiter ausholen. Ähm,
ich hab mittlerweile echt so meine Bedenken, was das anbelangt, wenn man Mädels irgendwie über
das Internet kennenlernt. Weil ich hab die Erfahrung gemacht, ich, ich verallgemeiner das jetzt nicht,
ja. Ähm, dass Mädels, die online sehr aktiv sind und da auch, ja wie sagt man so, online auf der
Suche sind, ja. Oder sich vielleicht auch an die ein oder andere Leute ranwerfen online. Dass die
sie oftmals nicht mal so alle haben. Und dazu will ich euch jetzt mal eine Sache erzählen. Vor fünf
Jahren oder so, schon ewig her, also da, wo ich auf YouTube noch ein bisschen Videos gemacht hab,
ähm, war ich auch mal in Kontakt mit so jemand. Und das, ich muss jetzt gucken, wie ich das jetzt
erzählen soll. Zumindest an sich war das gar nicht schlecht. Die war an sich, an sich hab ich mich auch
gut mit ihr verstanden. Die war nett, die sah auch relativ gut aus. Und an sich haben wir uns echt
ganz gut verstanden. Und ich hab mir die ganze Zeit so gedacht, irgendwas, irgendwas ist da merkwürdig.
Irgendwas, irgendwas stimmt da nicht. Sie hat erzählt, sie ist 21 und ähm, oder ich hab mir
irgendwie so gedacht, so nach zwei Wochen, irgendwie, irgendwas stimmt da nicht. Hab ich gesagt, ey, okay,
ähm, wie siehts dann aus, lass uns mal, lass uns noch mal treffen. Und eine Sache, die ich damals
nicht, nicht so genau gecheckt habe, aber die eigentlich heute voll offensichtlich ist,
ist, dass sie sich immer neue Ausreden ausgedacht hat, warum man sich nicht treffen kann. Aber
trotzdem, auf der anderen Seite, die übelste Flirt-Action online gestartet hat, die ganze Zeit.
Und ich, ich hab's halt, ich hab's halt irgendwie nicht gecheckt. Das, das, das Gipfelte dann darin,
dass wir, wir kannten uns nicht wirklich, ja. Nur online. Aber wie gesagt, sie hat die ultra,
ultra Flirt-Action online gestartet. Und auch mit Bildern und allem. Und das war, war die auch,
also das war jetzt nicht irgendwelche Fake-Geschichten oder so. Und auch teilweise
für Dinger, was sie für Dinger geschrieben hat, ey. So irgendwie so nach dem Motto, ey, gleich,
gleich geht's ab, ja. Und, und die Krönung der Sache war dann, dass sie dann irgendwann angefangen hat,
schon online irgendwie Drama zu machen. Und so war zum Beispiel, da bin ich auf Twitter,
da bin ich, ähm, bin ich einer Let's-Playerin gefolgt. Gefolgt, auf Twitter wohlgemerkt, ja.
Sonst nix. Und da hat die einen riesen Aufriss gemacht. Warum ich irgendwelchen anderen Mädels
auf Twitter folge, das mach ich doch nur, dass ich, ähm, heimlich mit denen schreiben kann.
Da hab ich mir schon gedacht, Alter, jetzt, jetzt wird's aber echt abgedreht irgendwie.
Und, ähm, naja, Ende vom Lied war, das hat nicht funktioniert, aber, ähm, also, dass man ein Drama
macht, weil man einer Let's-Playerin auf Twitter folgt, ist schon echt abgedreht. Ich will jetzt
auch nicht zu, nicht zu sehr ins Detail gehen, weil, da gab's dann schon noch ein paar Sachen,
die für alle Seiten nicht so, äh, wo ich, wo man nicht will, dass sie jeder weiß, ja, aber,
aber das mit Let's-Playerin folgen auf Twitter war schon, war schon echt so ein Highlight, wo ich
mir gedacht hab, die Mädels online, die spinnen alle ein bisschen. Was macht sie heute? Ich glaub,
die arbeitet bei irgendeinem Amt. Ich glaub, beim Umweltamt oder so war das. Stadt sag ich jetzt nicht.
Junge, dein Desktop, Wirechamp. Warum? Doch, perfekt. Ich mein, was will man denn mehr als Desktop haben?
Wenn ich einem männlichen Let's-Player gefolgt werde, ja, dann, ja, man weiß ja nie. Außerdem
ist es ja in der heutigen Zeit nur wirklich keine Chance, äh, keine Schande. Übrigens,
ich muss erst mal gucken, falls ich irgendwelche Subs verpasst hab, muss ich jetzt mal nachschauen,
wo ich das überhaupt sehe auf Streamlabs, Streamlabs, wo es Subs gegeben hat. Subs,
wen haben wir als letztes? Vor vier Minuten, ähm, Spread the Beast hat an T-Max Electronics
gegiftet. Dankeschön für den Sub. Ah, man sieht den Unterschied, ob Tier 1 oder Prime. Aha.
Ich entdeckte es jetzt auch zum ersten Mal. Die Icons, ne, das ist, ähm, ist halt Streaming-Account.
Ich ziehe halt einfach alles, was ich irgendwie hier im Stream mache, auf den Desktop und lasse
es dann da rumgabbeln, ja. Was war denn das jetzt? Was war das? Bits, ah, vier Bits, wie
viel sind das, vier Bits? Also, huge, huge Bits Donation, Poggers, keine Ahnung, wie
viele das sind, aber, sehr, sehr nice. Was sind denn? Vier Bits, ein Cent, äh, nein,
vier, vier Cent, ein Bit, ein Cent. Pog. Huge Pog. Ja, Leute, ähm, ich weiß jetzt
gar nicht so genau, was ich eigentlich, ah, total, Dankeschön für den Sub. Ich muss
mir jetzt irgendwelche, äh, Subsprüche ausdenken, dass ich nicht immer die gleichen Sachen
sagen muss. Eat Platz 1, Spread Beasts, oh, jetzt gibt's sogar, gibt's sogar lila Bits.
Ich muss euch jetzt mal was sagen, ähm, diese ganze Cheering-Geschichte und so, die ist
natürlich sehr nice, weil Easy Money und Easy Life und, äh, und so, aber ich persönlich
bin jemand, der hat die ganzen Bit-Geschichten und, und Top-Bit-Donator per Plugin ausgeblendet
auf anderen Channels. Weil das immer was vom, vom Chat wegnimmt und das nervt mich. Vielleicht
sollten wir mal Kirby ausmachen, was anderes anmachen. Ähm, übrigens, irgendjemand hat
auch gerade gefragt, was ich so für, ähm, Technik-Channels auf, auf YouTube empfehlen
würde. Äh, also mir fallen, mir fallen jetzt aus dem Kopf zwei Stück ein, die ich richtig
gut finde. Das eine ist ein bisschen was seriöses, das andere eher nicht. Also, wen, wen ich
richtig gut finde, ist, ähm, den Schweizer. Wenn's um, äh, so Micro-Controller-Geschichte
geht, guck ich mir den echt gerne an. Der hat, äh, viele interessante Tutorials. Ähm,
es ist nicht alles was, manche Sachen wie PoE und so, brauch ich, juckt mich nicht so
wirklich. Ähm, aber das ist richtig gut, wenn man sich für Micro-Controller-Kram interessiert.
Kann ich echt empfehlen. Auch wenn er, wenn er seine neueste China-Post auspackt, ist richtig
gut. Da lernt man nämlich auch, ähm, die ein oder anderen Geräte kennen. Hat er auch
so den typischen Schweizer Akzent. Ja, du musst dir mal sein Intro anhören. Hat er.
Hat er. Der sagt sogar, äh, am Anfang, was mit seinem Schweizer Akzent. So, und der
mit Abstand unterhaltsamste, so, Elektronik-Technik-Kanal ist der hier. Der hier. Das ist der beste.
Das ist der beste, ey. Also, also, man muss dazu sagen, der hat, der ist jetzt nicht irgendwie
unbekannt oder so, 2,6 Millionen Abos. Ich glaube aber, das ist ein Channel, der wäre
in Deutschland nicht erfolgreich. Ich glaube, das ist ein Channel, der wäre in Deutschland
nicht erfolgreich. Ähm, der ist zu anspruchsvoll und lustig gleichermaßen. Das kapiert, glaube
ich, so, dass, ähm, nur nach 15 Let's-Player-Gucker in Deutschland nicht. Ähm, aber das ist,
das ist wirklich lustig. Der schockt sich so gefühlt zehnmal pro Video. Und der hat
eine der besten Erklärungen, die ich je gesehen hab, zum Thema Stromwiderstand, Leitungswiderstand
und wie das alles zusammenhängt, die ich je gesehen hab. So gut erklärt und lustig
dabei, übelst huge. Noch mehr Bits, 500 Bits, krasser Scheiß, ja. 500 Cent, 5 Euro,
krass, nice, danke, huge brain. So, das sind, das sind so die zwei, ähm, das sind so die
zwei Channels, die mir jetzt spontan einfallen, die ich eigentlich, wo ich jedes Video gucke,
wo ich schon quasi darauf warte, dass sie ein neues Video machen. Ähm, es gibt, es
gibt noch mehr, aber da müssen wir mal Gedanken zu machen. Also, das sind aber die ersten,
die mir direkt einfallen. Klatzt du auch wie andere auf deinen Bauch, wenn jemand zappt?
Nee. Warum soll ich auf meinen Bauch klatschen? Ich meine, ich, ich hätte potenziell genug
Bauch, um da drauf zu klatschen, wenn jemand zappt. Ben Eater ist auch cool, ähm, ja,
stimmt, der ist mir jetzt gar nicht eingefallen. Vor allem die Grafikkartenvideos waren sehr
nice. Warum, vor allem, warum sollte man auf seinen Bauch klatschen? The Hook ist auch
ein guter Job. Ja, ist das nice. Sehr, sehr schön. Ähm, gucken wir mal, ob mein Tool
wieder verbugt ist heute. Drunk Stream bei 100er Subgoal. Ja, an Silvester vielleicht.
Gab's während deiner YouTube-Karriere eigentlich richtige, also so richtig, so richtig quasi
wie Fanboys nur als Grills eigentlich nur eins. Und nicht die, die ich gerade eben erzählt
hab, eigentlich nur eins. Aber ich bin jetzt nicht derjenige, der irgendwie, ähm, mit
seinen Videos hier die Scharen von, von Hotten-Fan-Grills anzieht, ja. Dazu fehlt natürlich
auch, dass ich nicht vor der Kamera rumspringe, weil da weiß ja gar keiner, was Sache ist,
ja. Hast du irgendwas mit Informatik oder Elektrotechnik studiert? Nein, hab ich nicht
studiert. Ich hab vor über 10 Jahren, 15 Jahren, fast, 15 Jahren, die Ausbildung gemacht
zur Empfang informatischer Systemintegration. Damals, so in grauer Vorzeit. Ja, ihr wisst,
wie mein Klo aussieht, das ist richtig. Wie alt ich bin? Nächsten Monat, im August,
bin ich 35. 35, ja. Tja, OKS, ja. Ich weiß, ich würd mich selbst auch nicht als 35 sehen.
Hab das falsche geklickt. Ich seh, also bei mir im Kopf bin ich höchstens, höchstens
paarundzwanzig. Ich würd mich auch nicht als 35 sehen. Also wenn ich an mein Alter denk,
bin ich nie an 35. Geht dem Fabian übrigens auch so. Aber siehst du, wie Fabian auch 20
Jahre jünger aus, als du bist? Nee, nicht ganz. Bei Fabian ist es extrem. Der Fabian
sieht ja wirklich aus wie, keine Ahnung, 23 oder so. Bei mir ist das Problem, dass ich
in der Mitte schon relativ wenig Haare hab. Also ich seh tatsächlich schon ein bisschen
älter aus. Also ich hab keine Platz, aber man sieht halt auch schon, dass da nicht mehr
nicht bei all zu viel ist hinten, ja. Also es ist übrigens, ähm, sehr, sehr, sehr
ziemlich verbreitet, glaub ich, dass heute Leute schon mit teilweise 25 anfangen, ähm,
quasi auf dem Kopf weniger Haare zu kriegen. Liegt bestimmt an der ganzen Handy-Strahlung.
Bist 24, bist grau, ja, ja. Kennst du die Seite Apollo in Realtime? Ja, das kenn ich,
das kenn ich. Ja, Moonmon hat auch so wenig Haare, das stimmt. Leute, ich hab keinen Plan,
was ich heute machen soll, ne. Ich hab einfach jetzt nur Streben angemacht, weil ich mir
gedacht hab, wenn ich jetzt, wenn ich schon Twitch Prime, oder wenn ich schon Partner
freigeschaltet wurde heute. Da mach ich jetzt einfach Streben an. Übrigens, ähm, für alle,
die vielleicht auch ein bisschen an Overwatch interessiert sind, habt ihr gesehen, dass
es einen neuen Patch gibt, also auf dem PTR, einen neuen Patch mit endlich, endlich, äh,
Role Queue, separaten Placements für die unterschiedlichen Rollen, oder auch ganz gute
Balancing-Anpassungen. Das könnte, es ist ja nicht so, als dass, dass das Leute, wie
sie, also, ich sag das seit zwei Jahren schon, oder mehr oder weniger seit Release, dass
man sowas braucht. Genauso wie ich seit Release gesagt hab, man braucht einen Spectator-Modus.
Allerdings, ich bin ja nicht der Einzige, warum sollten die auf mich hören, ähm, das
sagen so ziemlich alle anderen Leute, die sich intensiv mit dem Spiel beschäftigt haben,
auch schon seit Jahren. Und jetzt, als Blizzard endlich geschafft, das könnte sogar so weit
gehen, dass ich mir echt mal wieder, ähm, Overwatch antue, allerdings erstmal nicht
im Stream. Overwatch hatte keinen Spectator-Modus, nein, nein. Overwatch wurde als übelste E-Sport-Geschichte
gehypt, auch mit Overwatch League und allem, hatte aber bis vor kurzem keinen Spectator-Modus.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, wenn ein Game E-Sport ready sein kann, wenn es keinen Spectator gibt.
Einen schönen Panzer-Ei. Sub ist raus. Kann man nicht beim Subscriben irgendeine Nachricht
angeben, die dann angezeigt wird? Oder geht das nur bei Bits? Ach, nur beim Resub. Ah,
das ist natürlich huge. Das ist Big Brain von Twitch. Das verleiht die Leute natürlich
zum Resub, ne? Gerüchtet zu Overwatch 2 mitbekommen. Ah, da bin ich, da bin ich nicht
so, das glaube ich nicht so, dass in nächster Zeit Overwatch 2 rauskommt.
Jeden Tag Sellout-Stream, ja. Hast du doch irgendwas rumliegen, das du flashen kannst?
Ja, habe ich, denn vorgestern oder so ist eine neue Firmware rausgekommen für, ist das
Ding so? Kann man nicht merken, wie das heißt. Das ist so ein grausamer Name, das da. Vor
ein paar Tagen, vor zwei Tagen oder so, ist endlich Version 0.4 von der Custom-Filmware
für meinen Staubsauger erschienen. Und ich dachte mir, da können wir uns viel meinen
Staubsauger wieder flashen. Ja, Staubsauger-Flashen. Machs gut Patrick, bis denn.
Ist das eigentlich ein Mod für die Original-Firmware oder kompletter Recode? Das ist ein Mod für
die Original-Firmware. Allerdings haben sie halt den ganzen China-Cloud-Kram rausgebaut.
Die haben das ziemlich clever gemacht. Die Firmware ist halt so programmiert, das kenne
ich, das kenne ich, das habe ich letztens auch geguckt. Muss ich sagen, ich fand es
jetzt nicht so lustig, weil ich kann über irgendwelche Ragdoll-Animationen von Spielen
irgendwie nicht mehr lachen. Davon hat man zu viel schon gesehen. Ja, die haben das relativ
clever gemacht hier mit der Firmware. Die haben die Original-Version genommen oder die
nehmen die Original-Version von der offiziellen Staubsauger-Firmware und wiegen die Request
in die China-Cloud quasi lokal auf den Web-Server um, der von ihnen ist. Also im Prinzip ist
das hier mehr oder weniger die Original-Firmware, bloß dass die, die haben eine Firewall drauf
gehauen, dass das Ding nicht mehr mit China reden kann und sie biegen quasi, es hat gerade
geklingelt, ja, ja. Und die biegen dann alle Request um auf den lokalen Web-Server und
die Firmware denkt, sie reden mit der China-Cloud, in Wirklichkeit redet sie lokal mit dem Web-Server
hier. Das ist eigentlich ziemlich clever gemacht. Könntest du das nicht auch über den Router
machen, oh sorry Leute, der Router, und den Server bloß nachbauen. Klar, du kannst auch
den Raspberry irgendwo hinstellen, das drauf laufen lassen. Die haben es halt so gemacht,
dass alles auf einem Gerät läuft. BeatBot, ja, ja, könntest du wahrscheinlich machen,
aber ich meine, es ist ja ganz praktisch, wenn alles auf einem Gerät läuft. Aber ja,
das würde wahrscheinlich auch so funktionieren. Ich weiß allerdings nicht, nee, ich glaube,
ganz wird es nicht funktionieren, du brauchst so ein paar Firewall in Regel, die Request
blocken, die auf feste IPs gehen. Davoco, so sieht es aus. Siehst du mal, was ich für
den Streben alles hier wieder für Verluste erleide. Ups. Dann müsste man den Staubsauger
nicht mehr routen. Und das ist richtig. Dafür hast du dann immer noch China Spyware drauf.
Es ist kein Akt, den Staubsauger zu routen. Es ist nicht schwierig. Das machen wir morgen
dann im Stream. Morgen wird Staubsauger geroutet. Heute können wir das nicht mehr machen, weil
da muss ich erstmal die Ladestation unter dem Schrank ausbauen. Ich habe das Kabel unter
dem Schrank durch, hinter dem Schrank hoch an die Steckdosen, da muss ich erst wieder
auf die Erde rumkriechen, bis ich das rauskriege, da habe ich heute keinen Bock. Das machen
wir morgen. Morgen wird Staubsauger geflasht. Die Bits sind aktiviert. Ja, falls ich irgendwie
übersehe, Leute, wenn es hier irgendwie Huge Donation oder Bits oder sonst was gibt und
ich übersehe es, dann spampt mich wieder voll. Weil manchmal bin ich so am Schwätzen, dann
höre ich auch irgendwelche Sounds nicht. Da muss ich jetzt immer mal ein Auge auf Streamlabs
halten. In welcher Kategorie streame ich eigentlich gerade? Oh, Raiddy Germany habe ich übersehen.
Ich gucke mal, ob ich das sehe in Steamlabs. Nö. Doch, ein Bit. Kappa 1. Kappa 1, 2, 3.
Golden Kappa Check. Science and Technology. Leute, Golden Kappa Check. Ich weiß gar nicht,
ob es das überhaupt noch gibt. Das ist bestimmt Voraussetzung, dass man Twitch-Partner ist,
dass man Golden Kappa kriegt. Bist du eigentlich der einzige deutsche Partner in Science and
Technology? Glaube ich nicht. Aber ich finde es so geil, dass wir eigentlich der größte
Stream immer sind in Science and Technology. Einfach so, das ist halt schon nice. Die anderen
sind aber halt auch nicht so gut. Gibt bestimmt gute. Ich gucke an sich relativ wenig. Wisst
ihr, was ich auf Twitch aktuell ein bisschen blöd finde? Die hatten mal so eine Community-Übersicht
eingeführt, wo das ganze gruppiert war nach Speedrunning oder nach Roleplay oder sonst
was nach Dungeons and Dragons oder irgendwas in der Richtung. Das haben sie jetzt abgeschafft.
Ich weiß, es gibt jetzt Tags, aber ich fand das so viel einfacher, Channels zu finden,
die man noch nicht kennt, aber die einem gefallen. Weil ich bin jemand, der guckt auch Leute,
die Spiele spielen, die er nicht spielt. Ich gucke zum Beispiel auch öfters mal irgendwelche
Apex-Streams, obwohl ich das Game noch nicht einmal installiert hatte. Einfach so, weil
ich da gerne zugucke. Meistens finde ich die Leute allerdings dann nicht über Apex,
weil wenn du auf die Kategorie gehst, hast du erstmal alles voll mit Streams mit irgendwie
2000, 1000 plus Zuschauern, aber vielleicht gefällt dir ja der Stream mit 300 besser.
Also ich finde es allgemein schwierig gerade neue Streamer zu entdecken, die mir gefallen.
Das fand ich mit den Communities ganz gut und finde ich jetzt mit den Tags nicht so gut
gelöst. Ne, das normale Sub ist nicht Verlängerung.
Jedoch, du kannst das ankreuzen. Aber ich habe meine Subs immer ohne Verlängerung gemacht.
Ich will natürlich jetzt nicht sagen, dass ihr eure Subs ohne Verlängerung machen sollt.
Also Subs mit Verlängerung ist natürlich das beste, was es überhaupt gibt. Da könnt
ihr nicht vergessen zu suppen. Aber ich habe meine Subs immer ohne Verlängerung.
Du hast mich spontan entdeckt. Das finde ich nice. Was ich an sich auch wirklich cool
finde, ist, dass mittlerweile relativ viele Leute hier sind, die eben nicht über YouTube
gekommen sind. Ja, das kann sein, dass das automatisch drin war. Aber man kann es auf
jeden Fall auch machen, dass es nicht automatisch ist. Ja, das finde ich wirklich nice. Es sind
mittlerweile viele Leute, Stammzuschauer da, die es eben nicht über YouTube kennen. Was
auch der Grund ist, warum ich mich nicht so genannt habe wie auf YouTube. Ja, natürlich
sind viele hier von YouTube. Aber es gibt auch viele, die sind nicht von YouTube. Haha,
Reilly, das ist natürlich geil. Wolltest du gleich mal den Imposer hier... Imposer? Heißt
es Imposer? Imposter? Imposter? Imposer? Wie heißt denn das? Englische Vokabel in 2K19.
Könntest du dir vorstellen, Technikvideos für YouTube zu machen? Eine sehr gute Frage,
die ich mir vorgelegt habe. Ich habe mir nämlich schon Anfang des Jahres, oder eigentlich
Dezember letzten Jahres, überlegt, was kannst du auf YouTube machen, was dir selber gefällt,
was den Leuten auch gefällt, ohne dass du jetzt quasi einen neuen Channel machen musst
und ohne dass du den alten Kram komplett über Bord schmeißen musst. Dann bin ich zu dem
Schluss gekommen. Ich könnte tatsächlich mehr Technikvideos machen. Ich bin mir nicht ganz
sicher, in welcher Art und Weise. Ich werde weiterhin, wenn es Games gibt, die mich interessieren,
was machen und auch weiterhin Labervideos zu allen aktuellen Themen. Allerdings würde
ich gerne Technikvideos machen. Ohne mich jetzt direkt vor die Kamera zu setzen, allerdings
auch mit Kamera, um was zu zeigen. Aber ich meine, bei Technikvideos ist das nicht so wild.
Da machst du die Kamera schräg hinter dich und zeigst es halt auf dem Tisch. Da muss
ich noch gucken, wie ich das mache. Da muss ich mir hier eine Ecke hinstellen. Da muss
ich mir irgendwie eine Ecke einrichten mit Tisch. Vielleicht einen Queenscreen dahinter,
dass man auch mal einen schönen Hintergrund machen kann. Noch ordentlicher Beleuchtung.
Und genau, so machen wir das. Dann flashen wir Katja Krasavitz das Vibrator. Das ist
diese Idee, ey. Alter. Das wird bestimmt sowas von steil gehen. Dann müssen wir Clickbait-Überschrift
machen. Computer-Nerd entdeckt geheimen Trick. YouTuber hassen ihn dafür. Irgendwie sowas
in der Richtung. Max-Tech-Tipps. Naja, das wäre fast schon ein bisschen zu kopiert.
Aber von der Idee her, würde ich da schon gerne mehr Videos machen. Weil es gibt, ich
hab's ja am Anfang schon mal gesagt, es gibt relativ viele Videos, die sich im Chrome mit
Technik beschäftigen auf YouTube. Ich hab allerdings den Eindruck, dass es da oftmals,
wie soll ich das sagen, das kratzt an der Oberfläche. Allerdings auch, weil das gewollt
ist. Ich will den meisten Leuten gar nicht mal unterstellen, dass ich es nicht besser
machen kann. Die meisten YouTube-Zuschauer wollen das ja auch gar nicht großartig detailliert
wissen. Oder aber es werden nur Smartphones gezeigt oder Tablets gezeigt. Oder was auch
bei den Technik-Channels in letzter Zeit voll im Trend ist, da zeigen wir irgendwie
die Handys und danach, da zeigen wir Autos und sowas auf einmal, wo ich mir denke, okay,
das hätte ich jetzt eigentlich auf solchen Channels nicht vermutet. Aber Autos werdet
ihr bei mir wahrscheinlich nicht sehen, ihr wisst, dass das nicht wirklich mein Thema
ist. Aber ich werde wahrscheinlich versuchen, also wenn es so hinhaut, wie ich mir das vorgestellt
hab, danke Roffel1436 Twitch Prime. Übrigens Leute, wer ist sein Amazon-Account? Sein Amazon
Prime-Account noch nicht mit Twitch verknüpft hat, das ist seit, glaube ich, zwei Jahren
möglich. Man bekommt kostenlose Drops dafür in seinen Twitch-Account und man kann den
Streamer seiner Wahl kostenlos einmal im Monat mit einem Twitch Prime-Sub unterstützen. Sellout-Modus
activated. Danke für die Subs. Le Kickpuncher, Tynesaur, jetzt, oh, oh, der Sellout haut
rein, jetzt geht's ja Schlag auf Schlag hier. Redest du eigentlich wirklich über Twitch
Prime oder spielst du das Snippet nur mit dem Meme-Tool ab? Das müsste ich echt machen,
ich müsste mal so meinen besten, meinen bestmöglichen Sellout aufnehmen und den einfach immer wieder
abspielen. Wie gesagt Leute, heute gibt's einfach nur, machen wir einfach nur ein bisschen
Laberstream, wenn ihr irgendwelche Fragen habt, ich könnte mich im Prinzip fragen,
was ihr wollt, aber, oder Technik, sonst was, ist mir egal, ihr könnt mich alles möglich
heute fragen. Wir machen noch ein bisschen Laberstream und morgen flashen wir dann den
Staubsauger. Brauchst du noch ein Twitch Prime-Logo fürs Meme-Tool? Stimmt, brauche ich, das kann
ich ja immer einplanten, wenn ich meinen stündlichen Sellout mache. Was wollte ich
eben noch sagen? Technik-Videos auf YouTube, genau. Wie gesagt, würde ich wirklich gerne
machen und wenn das so klappt, wie ich mir das Ganze vorgestellt hab, dann will ich das
so machen, dass das schon einen relativ guten Detailgrad hat, dass man auch was mit anfangen
kann. Zum Beispiel, würde ich gerne mal ein Video drüber machen, wie man, wenn man zum
Beispiel, für sein Heimnetzwerk, wie man zum Beispiel sein Heimnetzwerk einrichten
sollte, rein von der Einteilung her, dass es eben sicher ist und bequem zu nutzen für
ein internes Netz, für WLAN, für einen Gäste-WLAN, für einen China-WLAN, ich weiß nicht,
wie es anders nennen soll, für einen Heimautomatisierungs-WLAN und auch was da so ein bisschen dahintersteckt,
warum man manche Sachen macht. Es gibt ja Leute, die sind heute immer noch der Meinung,
dass es eine gute Idee ist, wenn man in seinem Router DMZ anklickt und es gibt immer noch
Leute, die denken, dass DMZ tatsächlich bedeutet, man leitet alle Ports auf die PS4 weiter.
Das ist wirklich Pepehands an der Stelle. Das hat damit überhaupt nichts zu tun. Null.
Noch nicht mal der Name hat auch nur ansatzweise was damit zu tun. Aber es gibt immer noch
Leute, die sind der Meinung, DMZ gleich, ich leite alle meine Ports weiter auf die PS4.
Ridi DMZ steht für Demilitarized Zone. Ich weiß gar nicht, wozu. Zumindest was damit gemeint
es ist, du hast ein eigenes Netzwerk, wo von außen zugegriffen werden kann, wo von intern
drauf zugegriffen werden kann. Allerdings, wo von selber, für die Kisten, die da drin
stehen, nicht intern drauf zugegriffen werden kann. Demilitarized Zone. Genau. Gibt es in
zwei Varianten, wie man das Ganze machen kann. Es gibt, wenn das hier der Router ist, und
das hier ist der Router, das hier ist das Internet, das ist das Internet der Netzwerk, dann ist
die eine Sache, die man ganz gerne macht für eine DMZ, ist, dass man die quasi als eigenes
Netz hier daneben stellt, dass man hier daneben stellt. Das ist ganz unsicher Internet, das
ist ganz sicher intern das Netzwerk und zugegriffen werden darf von da nach da, von da nach da,
von da nach da, meistens zumindest, muss nicht unbedingt sein. Allerdings, es darf
nicht hier zugegriffen werden. Das ist nicht erlaubt. Das benutzt man dafür, wenn man
zum Beispiel eine Minecraft Server anbieten will, wenn man Minecraft Server bei sich daheim
hinstellen will, oder eine Website hosten will, oder vielleicht einen VPN braucht, oder sowas,
alles mögliche kann man das verwenden. VPN braucht man noch ein bisschen wer, Firewall,
oder eine andere Beischaltung dann. Die zweite Variante sowas zu machen ist folgendes, also
hier ist der Router in der Mitte, und die zweite Variante sowas zu machen ist, Eingangsrouter,
wir nennen das mal Eingangs-Firewall, interne Firewall, hier ist Internet, hier ist intern,
und da ist die DMZ. Das ist eigentlich fast schon die klassischere Variante, da brauchst
du halt zwei Router, beziehungsweise, eigentlich brauchst du zwei Firewalls für Router, müssen
sie unbedingt sein. Also eine Router allein bringt dir nichts, du brauchst auf jeden Fall
Firewalls dazwischen. Also eine Router brauchst du, weil das sind unterschiedliche Netze,
das ist auch eine Variante, das zu machen. Dann machst du Portweiterleitung, machst
du Portweiterleitung von hier nach hier, die dürfen auch raus, wie gesagt meistens, und
du machst Firewall-Freischaltung hier dazwischen. Und alles was von hier kommt, darf dann halt
hier nicht weiter. Das ist die andere Variante sowas zu machen. Ja, und es denken heute Leute
noch, dass DMZ bedeutet, man leitet alle Ports auf die Playstation weiter oder sowas. Das
ist ein unglaublicher Fail, das hab ich vor acht Jahren auf YouTube schon erzählt, und
die Leute glauben das immer noch. Paint ist beste. Weitere Softwaregeheimtipps, oh ja,
kann ich machen. Beatbrod fragt, du, warte mal, ich zeig das mal hier in meinem, dafür
haben wir das doch. Beatbrod fragt, du meintest ja man kann fragen was man will. Ich habe
mit meinem Raspberry Pi ein Netzwerk zu WLAN-Brücke gebaut. Allein ist schon mal huge brain. Jetzt
kann sich der Pi nicht mehr ins Internet verbinden, aber ich kann mich über LAN auf den Pi verbinden.
Außerdem kann beim booten DHCP, DHCP, achso, DHCP Klein, nicht gestartet werden. Hast
keine Idee woran das liegen kann. Es kommt ein bisschen drauf an wie du das gebaut hast.
Also ich vermute mal, dass das folgendermaßen funktioniert, dass der Raspberry sich im Klein-Modus
ins WLAN verbindet und du das dann gepridged hast. Also du lässt den Raspberry sich ins
WLAN einwählen. Ne, Sebaro, ich glaube nicht, ich glaube er hat was anderes gebaut. Du hast
den Raspberry sich per WLAN als Client am Access Point anmelden lassen und hast dann
dein ETH0 mit WLAN gepridged, oder? Der Raspberry ist am LAN dran. Achso, also hast du doch ein
Access Point gebaut. Achso. Das sind unterschiedliche Netze, hoffe ich mal, oder? Willst du das gleiche
Netz da und da haben, oder willst du unterschiedliche Netze haben? Du willst unterschiedliche Netze
haben, dann musst du auf jeden Fall schon mal einstellen, dass das IP Traffic weitergeleitet
wird aus dem Kernel aktivieren, dass das funktioniert und ja, wenn du die gleichen Netze haben willst,
musst du das pritschen. Wenn das das gleiche Netz sein soll, musst du das pritschen. Oder
weiß ich gar nicht, doch der Raspberry kann das. Also das ist einfach, ich habe mich noch
nie gebaut mit einem Raspberry, ich vermute mal das dürfte relativ einfach sein. Du sagst
deinem WLAN, du willst das Ganze im Access Point Modus betreiben und dann müsstest du
einfach dein Netzwerk mit dem WLAN pritschen und dann ist gut. Habe ich noch nie gebaut,
aber was ich dir empfehlen kann ist, bau das Ganze nicht selbst, sondern verwende, es gibt
nämlich ein Projekt, was dein Raspberry Pi zum Access Point macht. Verwende das hier.
Verwende einfach das hier, das macht das für dich. Das hier kenne ich nicht, was der da
ausgespuckt hat. Verwende einfach das hier. Dann hast du nämlich gleich noch ein schönes
Webinterface dazu und das macht dein Raspberry Pi zum Access Point. Man kann das selbst
bauen, aber ich meine, man muss ja nicht unbedingt, es sei denn, man interessiert sich dafür,
wie es technisch umgesetzt wird, das ist kein Ding, klar. Aber wenn man einfach nur will,
dass es funktioniert, dann würde ich sowas nehmen. Und das richtig schöne daran ist,
du kannst halt hier die komplette Config einstellen, du kannst das Ding als Repeater verwenden,
als Access Point verwenden, als was auch immer, sogar als rein klein kannst du das
Ganze verwenden, kannst updaten über das Webinterface, du hast sogar noch DHCP drauf
laufen. Dann nimm das hier, das ist schön, das ist gut. Und hat auch richtig schönes
Hexworth-Themen, wenn man das will. Das ist gut. Allerdings finde ich den Raspberry an
sich jetzt nicht unbedingt der beste Access Point, liegt allerdings schon daran, dass das
Ding nur eine On-Board-Antenne hat. Kann man den Pi eigentlich auch als Mesh-Device
einbinden? Warum nicht? Ich habe noch keine Gedanken zugemacht.
Was ist denn der Unterschied zwischen einem Container und einer VM? Da muss ich mal gucken,
da gibt es bestimmt schöne Bildchen zu. Ich suche mir mal ein schönes Bildchen raus und
dann kann ich was zu erzählen. Das sind grundsätzlich zwei komplett unterschiedliche Dinge.
Das scheint mir ein ganz sinnvolles, das scheint mir ein ganz gutes Bild zu sein. Allerdings
so wirklich schön zum erklären. Ist es nicht? Also ganz einfach gesagt, wir müssen uns drei
Fälle angucken. Man lässt einen Prozess direkt auf dem Host laufen, man lässt einen Prozess
im Container laufen oder man lässt einen Prozess in einer VM laufen. Es gibt zwischen den ersten
beiden Fällen kaum einen Unterschied. Wenn du deinen Prozess in einem Container ausführst,
ist das im Prinzip exakt das gleiche, wie du führst deinen Prozess auf dem Host aus.
Außer, dass es im Container ein paar Sandbox Maßnahmen gibt, die den Prozess vorgaukeln,
dass er manche Sachen sieht und nicht sieht, die er sehen würde, würdest du ihn direkt
auf dem Host ausführen. Der Container hat exakt den gleichen Container wie der Host,
das heißt du kannst den Containern beispielsweise auch keine Container-Module nachladen oder
sowas in der Richtung. Im Prinzip ist ein Container nichts weiteres wie ein bisschen
kernel Sandbox, wie ein bisschen Software Sandbox um einen Prozess. Fertig. Es gibt
keinen Unterschied so richtig zwischen einem containerisierten Prozess und zwischen einem
Prozess, den du direkt auf dem Host ausführst. Ganz im Unterschied zu einer VM. Eine VM ist
komplett virtualisierte, quasi emulierte Hardware. Das einzige was da halbwegs echt
drin ist in einer VM ist die CPU und das auch nur aus Performance Gründen. Die Grafikkarte
die die VM sieht, ist eine komplette Grafikkarte nachgebaut in Software. Die Soundkarte ist
eine komplette Soundkarte nachgebaut in Software, die dann unten drunter von der Virtualisierungssoftware
irgendwie auf das Hostgerät gemapt wird, aber das sieht die VM nicht. Du kannst auch
in der VM eine komplett andere CPU vorgaukeln. Du kannst beispielsweise nicht so ohne weiteres
auf Geräte zugreifen, die im Host drin sind von der VM. VM ist quasi ein komplett emulierter,
virtualisierter Rechner und das Betriebssystem da drin sieht auch nur das. Das Betriebssystem
in der VM ist eine komplett eigenständige Installation mit eigenständigem Kernel und
allem und hat auch keine Ahnung auf welchem Host sie drauf läuft. Der Container schon.
Der Container ist kein eigenes Betriebssystem, keine eigenständige Installation. Es ist einfach
nur ein bisschen gesandboxter, bisschen besser gesandboxter Prozess auf dem Host drauf.
Ist es bei Containern im Vergleich zur VM leichter auszubrechen? Ja auf jeden Fall.
Haben wir das verstanden, Void, Danny? Flow690, danke für den Sub. Ich glaube, du hast jetzt
gesehen, die anderen habe ich alle. Es ist huge Pog. Ich habe jetzt schon, also wenn
ich das hier so sehe, das ist so krass, man hat hier in Steamlabs so eine Historie mit
den letzten Subs. Ich habe so viele Subs schon heute gekriegt, danke euch, dass das mehr
ist als die erste Vorschau-Seite von Steamlabs überhaupt anzeigen kann. Also ich kann ja
mal gucken, wieviel die Seite anzeigen kann. 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12, 13,
14, 15, 16, 17, 18, 19, 20, 21 kann maximal die Steamlabs-Seite anzeigen hier und das
heißt, es sind sogar noch mehr. Richtig krasser Shit. Void, Danny, wozu du den Container überhaupt
brauchst? Das ist eigentlich relativ einfach erklärt, wenn du nicht die Vollvirtualisierung
von der VM brauchst, also sprich, wenn du nicht darauf angewiesen bist, dass dein,
oder ich muss, vergiss das, ich muss anders anfangen. Wenn dein Hausbetriebssystem ausreicht
für das, was du ausführen möchtest, wenn der alles hat, was du ausführen willst und
wenn du keine speziellen weiteren Sicherheitsanforderungen hast, die eine VM notwendig machen, würde
ich einfach immer den Container nehmen. Zum Beispiel hast du einen Linux-Host und möchtest
Windows-Software ausführen, dann geht das nicht den Containern, weil Windows ist ein
eigenes Betriebssystem. Da musst du voll virtualisieren, VM und Windows drin installieren,
in der VM. Windows denkt dann, es läuft auf einem eigenen Rechner und ist zufrieden. Wenn
du beispielsweise einen FreeBSD ausführen willst, also auch wieder ein anderes Betriebssystem,
dann musst du das in der VM machen. Du kannst keine FreeBSD-Sachen direkt unter Linus ausführen.
Ich weiß, dass es da theoretisch Sachen gibt, aber erstmal nicht. Sprich, wenn du Programme
für andere Betriebssysteme ausführen willst, dann brauchst du eine komplett eigene VM.
Ist ja irgendwie logisch. Oder wenn du sagst, ich will meine Software besonders gut abschotten,
isolieren, dann brauchst du auch eine VM. Wir hatten doch eben das Thema DMZ. Ich habe
meinen Host irgendwo stehen mit Linux drauf und möchte jetzt einen Minecraft-Server anbieten.
Da mache ich auf meinem Router eine DMZ an, mache Firewall-Freischaltung. Den Minecraft-Server
würde ich nie im Leben als Container laufen lassen. Warum nicht? Weil der Minecraft-Server
dann quasi direkt auf dem Host laufen würde mit ein bisschen Sandbox drumherum. Und ich
möchte ja ein eigenes Netz für meine DMZ haben, was sicherheitstechnisch abgeschottet
ist vom Rest. Und nachdem der Host-Rechner nicht in der DMZ steht, sondern wahrscheinlich
in dem Management-Netz oder vielleicht sogar bei mir intern, mache ich da eine VM und mache
da den Minecraft-Server drin. Und dann bin ich relativ sicher, weil ja der Minecraft-Server
in der eigenen VM läuft. Das heißt selbst, wenn irgendjemand, irgendeine krasse Hexer
meinen Minecraft-Server hackt in der DMZ, weil er kann da von außen drauf zugreifen,
ist das erstmal kein Problem für den Host unten drunter. Also ich würde eine VM immer
dann nehmen, wenn es securitymäßig erforderlich ist oder wenn ich Sachen ausführen will,
die ich nicht auf meinem Host ausführen kann. Eben zum Beispiel, weil es ein anderes Betriebssystem
ist oder spezielle Kernel-Module braucht. Irgendwas, wo der Host halt nicht dafür geeignet
ist. Kommt man eigentlich aus einer VM raus, also realistisch gesehen? Theoretisch schon
praktisch nicht. Waren wir was anderes, Open Hub oder Home Assistant? Home Assistant, aus
dem Grund, weil es finde ich das bessere Web-Interface hat, es in Python ist und nicht Java.
Was ist denn mehr für Multithreading geeignet, wenn man einen Single Thread Service laufen
lassen will? Also meinst du, was ist mehr geeignet, Container oder VM? In der Regel,
wenn es wirklich auf rohe Performance ankommt, um jeden Prozent Punkt, dann Container, allerdings
sind die Unterschiede rein CPU-mäßig zwischen dem Container und der VM. Es ist jetzt nicht
so, dass das doppelt so schnell wäre oder so. Das ist nicht so großartig. Der große
Unterschied zwischen Container und VM, würde ich sagen, liegt hauptsächlich im RAM-Verbrauch
und im Speicher-Verbrauch an sich. Container braucht keinen Speicher, braucht kaum extra
RAM, so gut wie nichts. Oder vor allem schon. Meine VM muss ein komplettes Betriebssystem
laufen lassen, allein schon. Deswegen braucht es mehr RAM. Ne, VM hatte ich nie. So, Pepega
hat das Wort aufgemacht. Haben wir beantwortet. Spackt mein Tool. Ah ne, der Beatbrot hat
das gerade eben wirklich gefragt. Kubernetes ist wieder ein bisschen anders, an einer anderen
Stelle angesetzt. Kubernetes ist an sich keine Virtualisierungslösung und auch keine Container-Software
an sich. Das ist ein Container-Management-Suite. Was sagen die eigentlich selbst zu sich?
Ja, genau. Es ist ein Open-Source-System zur automatisierten Bereitstellung, Skalierung
und Verwaltung von Container-Anwendungen. Was du damit machen kannst, ist zum Beispiel
mal angenommen, du hostest irgendwas. Die selber sagen immer orchestrieren. Ich finde
auch orchestrieren ist erstmal ein bisschen ein doofes Wort, aber das trifft es tatsächlich
ganz gut, weil es geht darum, dass du, wenn man sich mal so ein Orchester vorstellt, es
geht schon eher bei Kubernetes um das Dirigieren von Containern, als um das einfache, ich erstelle
mir einen Docker-File und starte einen Container. Ja doch, das trifft es eigentlich ganz gut.
Kubernetes dirigiert das Ganze eher. Du hast dann schon verschiedene Files, die die Konfig
von einem Container beschreiben. Allerdings, wofür Kubernetes zum Beispiel, ja, stell
dir vor, du hostest irgendwas und Kubernetes ist auch nicht das Einzige. Aber stell dir
vor, du hostest irgendwas. Du hast eine Web-Anwendung und du hast diese Web-Anwendung auf Kubernetes
laufen. Was du damit zum Beispiel machen kannst, ist, du kannst wunderbar skalieren, je nach
dem, wie viele Benutzer darauf zugreifen. Was natürlich besonders toll ist, wenn du
deine Anwendung gar nicht mal bei dir laufen lässt, sondern vielleicht in Azure oder bei
Google oder bei Amazon. Das ist natürlich besonders cool, weil du willst natürlich
nicht bei Amazon 50 Notes kaufen für eine Anwendung nachts um drei, wo keiner drauf
zugreift. Aber du möchtest vielleicht, wenn irgendeine News-Site über deine Anwendung
berichtet hat, möchtest du vielleicht ja auch alle Nutzer, die dann auf einmal auf
deine Seite aufmerksam werden, möchtest du dir die ja vielleicht alle auch abfackeln
können. Und dann kannst du dynamisch skalieren lassen, indem du einfach noch 20 neue Container
hochfährst. Alter, Flow690, was ist jetzt los? Huge! Der Flow690 verschenkt 1, 2, 3,
4, 5, 6 Abos und zwar an PC Lustig, an Shadow 00, an Quay 1, an Capasco und an allen Calypto.
Flow690 wird das random ausgewählt oder wie funktioniert das, wenn man giftet? Muss man
die Leute von Hand auswählen? Ich hab noch nie gegiftet. X-Shadow-Ghost, danke für
den Sub. Ach du hast gerade gefragt, ab wann man suppen kann, ab vor seit einer Stunde
oder so. Ach kann man beides machen, ok. Huge! Pock! Ultra nice. Fulltime Streamer, wenn.
Aber wenn mit 3000 Euro im Monat bezahlst. Dann Fulltime Streamer, easy. Leute, wir haben
uns, wir haben uns letztens bald aus Spaß auf der Arbeit tatsächlich überlegt, ob wir
uns nicht SysAdminTV Domain registrieren können oder Twitch-Account erstellen und da haben
wir festgestellt, das geht nicht, weil du nichts erstellen darfst mit TV drinnen. Sonst hätten
wir hier, nein, wir hätten nie von der Arbeit gestreamt, Blödsinn. Aber wir haben es aus
Spaß überlegt, ob das nicht sogar möglich wäre. Rekfress, danke für den Sub. Ok,
vielleicht, ich mach mal kurz, warum hab ich, warum haben meine Follower eigentlich den
Papagei, den Papagei als, als Emote und Subs haben den Zombie. Noch mehr Subs, das ist
ja huge heute. Hawks, danke für den Twitch-Prime-Sub. Huge Prime aller Leute heute hier. Ähm,
BeatBot, das hab ich mir sogar schon mal aufgeschrieben, das hab ich vor einzubauen. Er schreibt, man
könnte ja mal nen Bot bauen, der dem Chat erlaubt Memes vor Memetool zu triggern. Hab
ich mir schon überlegt, gibt es übrigens schon fix und fertig, ne, müsste man eigentlich
gar nicht einbauen in das Tool, aber das hab ich mir schon aufgeschrieben, als das eingebaut
wird. Max, verkaufst du Badewasser? Ja, demnächst geh ich in den kompletten Sellout-Modus über,
da wird alles verkauft. Badewasser, benutzte Socken, alles. Alles wird verkauft. Dreck von
der Tastatur, Krümel aus der Tastatur, ähm, keine Ahnung. Abgekratztes Zeugs vom Handy,
alles, man kann heute mit allem Geld verdienen. Haar, ich war gerade beim Friseur. Vor drei
Stunden war ich beim Friseur, hätt ich mal mitnehmen sollen. Keks, Krümel, alles, Essensreste,
das wird jetzt ausgeschlachtet bis zum Letzten. Wann kommt das Gentoo Walkthrough, wenn ich
anfange Gentoo zu verwenden? Wohnt der Friseur nicht im Osten? Doch, ich war nicht beim Friseur,
ich war nur beim Friseur. Kennste die Hornbach Werbung mit den Asiaten? Ne. Ähm, ich muss
erst mal gucken, wie ich in Steamlabs einstellen kann, dass meine Subscriptions den Papagei
bekommen. Moment, wir testen das jetzt mal. Kommt jetzt der Papagei? Haar, hat es nicht
gespeichert, haar? Hat es das nicht gespeichert? Will das der Papagei kommt, wenn einer subscribt?
Save. Haar, ich weiß warum nicht. Leute, ich muss euch kurz ausmachen. Der Link stimmt
nicht. Der Link stimmt nicht. Jetzt stimmt der Link. Mal ausprobieren, ob es jetzt funktioniert.
Haar. Heute nur Laberstellts, heute nur Laberstellts, ich hab nix geplant. Morgen wird der Staubsauger
geflasht. Wobei wir bräuchten auch ein besseres Subgif. Ah Leute, ich muss mir was überlegen.
Was könnte man als schönes? Was könnte man als schönes Subgif nehmen? Ich probier mal
was aus. Follows, Subscription, Upload, Select, Save. Ok, um, ob es jetzt funktioniert? Test
Subscription, Moment. Ah, so ist es doch schon besser, oder? Da gibt es bei Follows den normalen
Parrot und bei Sub gibt es dann den Party Parrot. Hast du den Link gesehen? Nee, hast
du den Link? Meinung zu Windows Sandbox. Ist das jetzt irgendwas neues, was ich noch nicht
kenne? Oder ist das die übliche Geschichte mit MP Engine, Virenscanner, oder ist das
was Neues, Tynesaw? Wenn das was ganz Neues ist, dann sagt es mir nichts. Dann hab ich
es mir so nicht angeguckt. Die Subcatch Idee, du machst ein virtuelles Tamagotchi in die
Ecke und es wird nur gefüttert, wenn gesubbt wird. Subt, keiner droht es zu sterben. Oh,
huge. Das ist hier Leute, man. Das muss ich mir aufhören. Das programmieren wir im Stream
dann. Das programmieren wir im Stream. Der Keks muss gefüttert werden, sonst geht der
immer mehr kaputt.
Alter, ist der Hornbachclip abartig. Was heißt denn bitte schön Flashen, neue Software
auf dem Gerät drauf kopieren. Neue Software auf dem Gerät drauf kopieren. Hast du den
Link gesehen? Ja, hab ich. Was für einen Switch oder allgemeinen Hardware würdest du
empfehlen? Genau, was für einen Switch oder allgemeinen Hardware? Ich muss jetzt mal kurz
schauen. Ich hab immer noch OBS im Bild. Ups, fail. Okay, jetzt hab ich den Chat wieder
runtergescrollt. Das ist gerade zu viel. Genau, ich wollte das hier vom Horx. Also, was für
einen Switch oder allgemeinen Hardware würdest du empfehlen, wenn man sich LAN in sein Zimmer
legen möchte? Und damit man auch mal ein wenig rumspielen kann. Router besitze ich bzw.
meine Eltern eine Fritzbox. Was meint ihr mit rumspielen? So ein bisschen Netzwerkkrams
ausprobieren und lernen. Also für Netzwerkkrams zum Lernen, wenn man sich dafür interessiert,
kann ich eigentlich auch nur das wiederholen, weil ich sonst immer wiederhole, holt euch
Mikrotik Sachen. Mikrotik Sachen sind günstig, verbrauchen wenig Strom, haben ordentliche
Performance für das Geld und sind an sich ziemlich gute Hardware. Holt ihr was kleines
von Mikrotik? Ich meine, du brauchst eigentlich ja nicht wirklich einen Switch. Wenn du nur
den Rechter anschließen willst, kannst du auch direkt eine Fritzbox machen. Wenn du
noch mehrere Geräte hast, dann lohnt sich das natürlich. Dann würde ich was von Mikrotik
nehmen. Da würde ich hier irgendwie zum Beispiel den da. Das ist jetzt kein reiner Switch,
das ist eigentlich ein Router mit einem 5-Port-Switch. Ist aber sowohl von der Hardware, die drinnen
ist gut, das Betriebssystem, was drauf ist, ist super umfangreich. Also wenn man netzwerkmäßig
was lernen will, sind die Dinge sehr gut. Und kostet auch nicht so viel. Die Lite-Variante
kostet 50 Euro, der eine kostet 70 Euro. Das ist natürlich viel mehr als du brauchst
letztendlich. Geht eigentlich mit der Musik gerade ab. Es sind im Endeffekt mehr Sachen
als du brauchst, hat der Gigabit, klar. Es sind letztendlich mehr Leistungen als du brauchst,
ja. Aber du kannst auch mal ein bisschen rumspielen mit unterschiedlichen Netzen, mit WLANs und
so. Das ist halt mit einem, also unterschiedliche Netzen und Routen ist halt mit einem reinen
Switch. Also mit einem reinen Switch geht es gar nicht. Hast du einen ein bisschen moderneren
Switch, geht es aber. Die mögen alles andere als Switchen meistens nicht, performanstechnisch.
Und hier kannst du also zum Ausprobieren finde ich generell auch zum Netzwerkzeug lernen,
ist das das beste Gerät was es gibt, wenn es erschwinglich sein soll und man es auch
sinnvoll einsetzen will. Man kann sich auch alte Cisco-Dinger kaufen, wenn es einem wirklich
um die Hardcore-Netzwerkgeschichte rein zum Lernen geht. Das Problem ist allerdings,
dass die Cisco-Dinger, die alten, nur zum Lernen taugen. Die will man sich nicht daheim
hinstellen. Die sind laut, die verbrauchen viel Strom und oftmals sind die auch von der
Performance her so letztes Jahr tausend, dass die oftmals nur 10.000 haben. Oder aber wenn
sie schon moderner sind, dann sind sie ziemlich teuer auch gebraucht. Das heißt, ich finde
man kann mit dieser MikroTik-Geschichte kann man wirklich nichts verkehrt machen. Das ist
der beste Übungsrouter, von dem man auch was hat. Und fünf Ports reichen einem normalerweise
ja auch. Und die Ports sind nicht einfach nur per CPU geswitcht, da ist auch ein Hardware-Switch
drin, also man hat auch ordentliche Switching-Performance. Huge Sub! Jetzt muss ich erstmal warten bis
da steht wer es ist. Wer ist es? Melodize! Nice! Danke für den Sub! Twitch Prime! So
jetzt muss ich erstmal in mein Tool gucken, was ich da wieder alles übersehen habe. Danke
für's Zuschauen, es war sehr schön. Also wirst du auf jeden Fall viel Spaß dran haben. Du hast
den, den ich empfohlen habe, bestellt. Dir habe ich nicht den Hex PoE empfohlen, dir habe
ich den 24-Port, den CRS 8-2, CRS 3-2-8, 3-2-6 empfohlen, ne? Was war bisher das beste Video
aus deinem Discord? Boah, weiß ich nicht gerade. Kam mit Windows 10 Build 1903 oder so, ist
eine VM die mit Windows mitgeliefert wird, ist bei der deutschen Sprache derzeit ein
bisschen RIP, keine Ahnung wie wir es mit... Was gibts das? Sandbox? Wie heißt das? Was
muss ich ausführen? Windows, Sandbox, hab ich noch nie gehört. Windows Sandbox aktivieren.
Deskmodder.de klingt schon mal super vertrauenswürdig, die Seite. Ok, wie verwendet man das? Systemsteuerung,
Suche, Einstellungen, Apps, was? Ach man muss das über Features hinzufügen machen. Ok,
machen wir mal. Sandbox, ne, äh, Feature, add, turn on Windows Feature, oh ne jetzt ist
OBS wieder kaputt, ne? Moment Leute, OBS geht wieder. Geht OBS wieder? Ja, geht wieder.
Sandbox, ach was muss man suchen? Programme und Features. Windows Sandbox heißt das auch
noch. Windows Sandbox, enable dependency required to run Windows Sandbox Scenarios.
Ähm, wisst ihr ob man neu starten muss nach der Installation? Wenn man neu starten muss
mache ich es lieber in der VM, wobei eine VM in der VM, das wird wahrscheinlich in der
Windows nicht richtig funktionieren. Ja muss man das scheiße, da kann ich das nicht ausprobieren.
Ne, wir können zwar mit nested Virtualisierung ausprobieren in VM, da bin ich mal gespannt
ob das funktioniert. Leute, das probieren wir jetzt mal aus. Wir virtualisieren Windows
in Windows in Windows. Was sind die richtige VM? Das da, das da, das da. Ich glaube das
hier. Wie viele VMs in einer VM hast du schon mal aufgesetzt? Ich hab mal ESX in VM in
Workstation installiert und dann in ESX. Wait, warte mal. Warte mal, ne ne ne, wie war das?
Genau, und dann in ESX in Linux, das hat funktioniert. Ähm, was ich auch mal gemacht hab, ich hab
einen Windows Server installiert unter VMware Workstation und darin dann, ähm, und darin
dann Hyper-V und darin dann noch ein Windows, weil ich testen wollte wie das mit Remote
Desktop 3D Beschleunigung mittlerweile ist. Hat natürlich nicht richtig funktioniert.
Ist das nicht ein bisschen viel RAM? Naja, wenn man nichts macht braucht der Kram auch
nicht so viel RAM. Okay, dann probieren wir das jetzt mal aus. Da ist noch der Kram vom
letzten Mal offen. Close, close, close, close, on KS. Okay, wir machen, wir machen die Firewall
mal wieder on. Probieren wir mal aus. Wir probieren das jetzt mal aus. Feature, Feature,
add, sehen wir das, add Feature und dann Windows Sandbox. Was? No Virtualization Capabilities.
Dann müssen wir Windows mal ausschalten. Jetzt mal den Big Brain Play überhaupt. Wir
schalten Windows aus und schalten Nested Virtualisierung ein. Wenn ich mich dran erinnern
könnte wo das geht, da. Äh, den Rest virtualisieren wir mal nicht. Und jetzt können wir auch
in der VM VMs anlegen. Big Brain. Inception, ja. Stripes, es ist überhaupt kein Ding.
Kann jeder hier auch zugucken, sich einbringen und ohne, ohne zusammen. Ja, das ist überhaupt
kein Ding. Subskribieren. Okay, mal gucken ob es jetzt funktioniert. Add Feature. Findet
ihr das eigentlich auch so lächerlich? Für alle denen das schon aufgefallen ist, dass
man unter Windows standardmäßig kein Telnet hat, sondern dass man um Telnet zu installieren
sagen muss Turn Windows Features on und off Telnet Client. Was macht Intel VTD eigentlich?
Das ist ja eben die Hardware Virtualisierung. Guck hier, Bam, Sandbox kann installiert werden.
Der Sebaro. Der Sebaro. Stripes 007. Der Sebaro ist schon echt ein netter Typ, ne?
Restart. Jawoll. Übrigens, jetzt wo wir gerade bei Telnet sind, habe ich euch eigentlich
das hier schon gezeigt. Machen wir mal Vorlesung aus. Habe ich euch das hier schon gezeigt.
Telnet. Parrot. Live. Gibt es gar nicht mehr. Gibt es es nicht mehr. Das gibt es nicht
mehr. Das gibt es nicht mehr. Try it. Mit Curl. Ach, mit Curl ging es nicht mit Telnet
auch. Hey, da ist es. Man musste es Curl und nicht Telneten. Da ist er. Ich dachte man
musste es Telneten, aber man musste es Curl und das reicht. Man musste es Curl und das
ist auch so ein total beknackter Satz. Okay, ähm, was macht unsere Windows in Windows
Installationen? Ah, ist neu gestartet. Nur als Vorwarnung, wenn dein Windows jemals
als Sprache was anderes als Englisch hatte, wird das nicht funktionieren. Nein, hat es
zum Glück nicht. Towerblinken, Lights, NL. Keine Ahnung, ob es das noch gibt. Okay und
wie geht es jetzt weiter? Sandbox. Windows Sandbox, da ist es. Yes. Und jetzt? Nee,
ich habe gerade die Seite aufgemacht, die ist 40404. 404 oder ist es DNS? Not found.
Nee, da ist 40404. Da probiere ich das mal aus kurz. Was macht das jetzt noch was? Macht
das jetzt noch was?
Und du? Ach doch, gibt es noch. Ach, das ist das ASCII Star Wars. Ähm, wer hat es
geschrieben? Das ist das ASCII Star Wars. Genau, ja, das kenne ich noch. Kann es sein,
dass die Nested vor allem nicht mehr Hardware beschleunigt, virtualisiert? Ja, höchstwahrscheinlich
nicht. Also mit ordentlicher Oberflächen beschleunigt. Guckt mal Leute, Windows in Windows, ich
meine es ist lahm as fuck. Ihr seht es ja hier. Aber ich meine, das ist mal Meta, oder? Windows
in Windows in Windows. Niko Rock, Twitch Prime, Dankeschön. Gibt sogar den Party Parrot
hier. Na das, ich glaube, das ist weltweite Twitch Premiere. Windows in Windows in Windows.
Live auf Twitch. Das gab es noch nie. Was kann man da drin jetzt machen? Einfach irgendwas
ausprobieren und dann wieder wegwerfen oder wie? Jetzt wird es ganz hart. Jetzt wird es
ganz hart. Edge aufmachen. Und dann mache ich meinen Stream auf da drinnen. Das ist
Next Level Shit. Windows in Windows in Windows. Und dann den Stream selbst angucken. Oder
das Oh Homeworld, das ist eine gute Idee. Oder darin, Leute, Next Level Shit. Darin
installieren wir jetzt WSL. In WSL installieren wir Wine. Und mit Wine machen wir Notepad
auf. Das probieren wir mal aus, oder? Was sagt ihr dazu? Das müssen wir ausprobieren.
Twitch Mason abonniert Stufe 1. Dankeschön. Geht Wine in WSL? Ich habe ehrlich gesagt
keine Ahnung. Boah, ist das lahm. Lahm as fuck, Alter. Wine in WSL. Ich weiß keine Ahnung,
ob das funktioniert. Running Wine in WSL. Geht nicht. Time to unsequit on top. Können
wir auch machen. Welcome to Edge. Geh weg. Cortana. Oder was auch immer. Geh weg. Rasp
AP hat super funktioniert. Danke für den Tipp. Bitteschön. Nice. Funktioniert. Boah,
ist das langsam. Boah, ist das langsam. Boah, das kann man nicht benutzen. Okay. Okay, Leute.
Twitch. Wo blort es? As zu wenig RAM, wahrscheinlich. Stimmt vielleicht. Das kann tatsächlich
sein, dass ich der VM zu wenig RAM gegeben habe. Wie viel RAM hat die VM? Wie viel RAM?
Die können auch ein bisschen mehr RAM verkraften. Die können auch ein bisschen mehr RAM verkraften,
die VM. Hier. Ich habe doch gerade oben reingelegt. Woop. Lords. Kann es sein, dass es da nicht
drinnen tippt? Ich glaube, ich glaube, jetzt ist es vorbei. Ich glaube, jetzt ist es vorbei.
Jetzt ist Schluss. Toll. Das mag nicht mehr. Das mag nicht mehr. Das ist es vorbei. Okay,
wir probieren nochmal was. Wir probieren nochmal was. Power off. Suspend. Wir geben dem Ding
jetzt nochmal mehr RAM. Ich will gucken, ob das funktioniert. Wir geben dem Ding jetzt
nochmal mehr RAM. Wir geben dem jetzt 8. Wir geben dem Ding jetzt 8G RAM. 2 CPUs. Das sollte
eigentlich reichen, oder? 2 CPUs. 3. 3 CPUs. Kommt, Leute. Der Rest muss zum Streamen reichen.
Der restliche Kern muss für OBS reichen. Nicht 4. Ruggels. Die Grafikkarte. Sound. Sound.
Mach mal raus. Printer. Mach mal raus. Alles, was ich brauche, mach mal raus. Display. 1G.
Fuck. Okay. Gut. Start. Ach, Moment. Ich habe ja 6 Kerne. Omega 0. Warum weiß Twitch Chat
besser, wie viele CPU-Kerne ich habe, als ich selbst? Wie kann das sein? Warum weiß das
Twitch Chat besser? Ich habe 6 Kerne. Stimmt. Passiert ja nicht. Stimmt. Twitch Chat hat
mein PC-Kaufvideo gesehen. Es ist aber nicht nur, ihr habt nicht nur mein Kaufvideo gesehen.
Twitch Chat ist ja auch hier, ist ja auch automatisch bei mir immer Q-Chat. Und Q-Chat kennt sich
aus. Q-A-F-Chat. Okay, es ist schon mal eine ganze Ecke schneller hier in der VM jetzt.
Okay, Sandbox. Yes. Okay, gucken wir mal in der VM zu, was da passiert. Performance.
Er ist bei weitem nicht so ausgelastet wie vorher. Gleich Smokersmoke angesagt. Ich sage es euch.
Vielleicht kackts ab. Was Sandbox, der da eigentlich so lange rum? Er stellt da jedes
Mal ein neues Windows-Image, wenn ich die Sandbox starte. Rauchmelder am Start, ja.
In jedem Raum 10 Jahre C-Wave Rauchmelder. Inklusive über C-Wave testbare Batteriestand.
Hast du die 7 nicht auf 5 GHz laufen? Die erkennen bloß 3,7. Ja, anscheinend läuft
er auch nur auf 3,7 Grad. Gucken wir mal auf dem Host. Host Performance. 4,9. Die VM erkennt
es. Vmg Bailet. VM will es nicht starten. Tja Max, Electronics. Hast du das Fenster aufgehabt?
Was ist hier los? Wir haben gerade Windows in Windows in Windows virtualisiert. Ram wird
wieder teurer. Da muss ich jetzt nochmal einkaufen. Ich brauche noch. Also, so. Nochmal so 16G kann
ich gebrauchen. Hat es eben auch so lange gedauert bis es gestartet ist? War das eben
auch so langsam? Ich meine, der macht ja gar nichts. 3x Kerne, 3x langsam. Das klingt
logisch, ja. Da tut sich ja gar nichts. Wisst ihr was? Mal gucken wie die Ram-Auslastung
auf dem Host ist. Naja, da geht noch was. 4,9 von 16G, was willst du denn? Ach nee,
sogar nur 14,3 von 16G. Was brauchst du denn so viel RAM? Siehst du, für VM, inner VM
und noch VMs nebenbei laufen lassen. Mehr RAM, außerdem ist mehr RAM nie verkehrt.
Also, ich hätte schon gerne 32G drinne. Ich habe damals halt kein 32G gekauft, weil das
auch teuer war. Das hat 280 Euro gekostet, als ich den Rechner geholt habe. Aber ich
habe auch so brain dead wieder irgendwelche komischen RGB-Rams geholt. So lange hat es
das erste Mal nicht gedauert, Leute. So lange hat es nicht gedauert. Guck mal, wie man 33%
CPU-Last erzeugen kann, wenn man einfach nur den Desktop markiert. Windows, lul. 33% CPU-Last
durch Desktop markieren. Schafft es erst mal unter irgendeinem anderen Betriebssystem.
Guckt euch hier. Wenn ich das in einem Auslastungs-Graf in einem Linux-Server sehen würde, würde
ich sagen, den Java-Prozess hat sich aufgehängt oder so. Aber nein, unter Windows ist das einfach
die Maus auf dem Desktop bewegt. Ich glaube, das startet nicht. Ich gucke mal gerade, wie
viel der RAM kosten würde, wenn ich mir jetzt noch, wir haben zwar letztens geguckt, aber
ich habe es schon wieder vergessen. Also, wenn ich mir jetzt noch mal meinen RAM kaufen
würde, dann müsste ich bezahlen. Erst mal gucken, wie mein RAM überhaupt hieß. Wie
heißt mein RAM? EESGIL. Hier, da. Da. Amal-Speicher. GIF. DDR4. DDR4 mit Beleuchtung, genau. Trident,
die tatsächlich unter nur mit Beleuchtung. Ne, wir machen das jetzt anders. Wir suchen
nach Zugriffszeiten. Was haben wir hier? CL14. Hä? Wie kann man da nach suchen? Ich habe
schon wieder vergessen, wie haben wir denn danach gesucht? Also, es ist auf jeden Fall
3200er RAM. RGB. Da. Ist er das? Ne. Das ist er auch nicht. Wo ist mein RAM? Wo ist mein
RAM? Da. CL141434. 16er Kit. Das da müsste das sein. Was genau ist der Unterschied zwischen
den zwei Dingern? Erkennt da irgendwie einer den Unterschied? Außer, dass der X hinten
dran steht, aber die Timings sind doch alle gleich. Nur, dass der mit X 10€ mehr kostet.
Hab ich denn für ein RAM? Hab ich mit X oder ohne X? Erkennt man von hier nicht, ne? Doch
hier. Hier, jetzt hab ich rangezoomt. Erkennt man nicht. Das X steht für besser. Ich hab
den Geizhals-Link in der Beschreibung. Da guck an. Ich hab den da. Ohne X. Ich hab
den ohne X, Leute. Ohne X. Gegen das Preisentwicklung öffnen und dann auf alles, ne? Ja, hier
habe ich den Rechner irgendwie geholt, wo es übelst teuer war. Notebooks billiger. Ich
finde den Shop eigentlich ganz gut, habe schon öfters was bestellt. Ich glaube, es wird
mal Zeit für noch 16GB RAM. Ich glaube, es wird Zeit, Leute. Was macht eigentlich unsere
Windows-VM? Ich glaube, das geht nicht mehr. Ich glaube, das ist kaputt, Leute. Ich glaube,
jetzt ist RIP. Das geht nicht mehr. Windows-VM ist kaputt. Danke für den Sub. XFATAL1337.
Richtig Elite. Einfach Windows-Taktik stoppen starten. Hast du mal die Sendbox außen wieder
eingestellt? Gerade eben. Zur Hydrant. Powerstart. Party Parrot. Danke für den Sub. Sind noch
andere Mods da? Gute Frage, Sebaro. Wenn nicht... Wenn nicht, müsste ich mich mal ernsthaft
überlegen, ob wir nicht vielleicht noch irgendjemanden modden. Notebooks billiger. Was sagt der MaxElectronics?
Er sagt, Notebooks billiger ist mega low. Laptop zurück schicken müssen und die haben
vier Monate gebraucht, um es überhaupt zu merken und es erst weiter bearbeitet, als
ich mit einem Anwalt gekommen bin. Frist setzen. Immer Frist setzen. Immer Frist setzen. Da
können die sich nicht rausreden. Leute, ich glaube, das ist tatsächlich das typische
Microsoft Phänomen. Es geht beim ersten Mal und danach geht es nicht mehr. Da kann ich
nichts machen. Diese News. Diese News immer, ey. Das Edge-Icon stimmt. Das ist irgendwie
so. Das ist Mini-Edge. Mini-Edge. Mal angenommen. Jetzt mal ganz doofe Frage. So, ich als Win-Ausdruck.
Mal angenommen, ich habe die Edge-Verknüpfung aus Versehen gelöscht. Wie kriege ich die
Edge-Verknüpfung wieder hin? Edge. So? Nee. Pin. Suchfeld. Edge. Und dann? Nee. Rechtsklick.
Edge start und rechtsklick in die Taskleiste. Und dann? Und dann? Wie mache ich eine Verknüpfung
auf den Desktop? Okay. Shift. Shift, rechtsklick in der Taskleiste und dann im Ordner eröffnen
das Edge-Icon erstellen. Shift, rechtsklick. Du musst die App ans Startmenü anheften.
Okay, okay. Aber im Startmenü geht es auch nicht. Guck. Edge. Okay. Pin from start. Edge-Browser.
Ah. Alter, ist das umständlich. Warum ist sowas einfach so kompliziert? Und warum kann
ich es darüber ziehen und darüber nicht? Kann ich es darüber ziehen? Auch nicht. Hä?
Alter Windows. Ist das jetzt wirklich den hier ernst, oder? Tja Leute, ich würde mir
wirklich gerne die VM angucken. Die Windows Sandbox. Aber ich glaube wir haben zu viel
RAM jetzt. Okay, wir machen das anders. Wir machen das anders. Das ist bestimmt kaputt.
Das ist bestimmt kaputt, weil wir dir, weil wir dir zu viele CPUs gegeben haben. Also
wir geben dem Ding jetzt wieder weniger CPUs und wir geben dem, dem, dem bloß, bloß
6GB RAM. Dann geht es bestimmt. Und da sagt Max, mehr RAM ist immer gut. Was kann ich
dafür, wenn Windows 10 in der Meinung ist, mehr RAM ist schlecht. Vielleicht ist das
kaputt, weil du die VM gekillt hast, während die Sandbox lief. Okay, wäre auch Windows
Logik, ja. Ich könnte, ich könnte das Feature nochmal deinstallieren und wieder installieren,
jetzt gehts dann. Okay. Sandbox. Yes. Jetzt macht er was. Jetzt macht er was. Ohne Scheiß
Leute, vorhin hat er nix gemacht. Jetzt macht er was. Das Edge. Jetzt gehts. Ernsthaft.
Windows. Haha, so schlecht. Windows Logik. 4 CPU Kerne, 8GB RAM. Ne, das geht nicht.
2 CPU Kerne, 6GB RAM. Ah, jetzt funktionierts. Okay, jetzt aber. Edge. Voll am Limit hier,
voll am Limit. For real, warum geht das Scheiß nicht? Weil Windows, das ist ja das Problem,
was ich mit Windows hab. Es ist nicht nachvollziehbar, warum was geht und warum nicht. Okay. Woop
Lords Twitch. Jetzt sucht er bestimmt in Bing oder so Dinger. Sucht er in Bing? Jetzt
vor allem installieren nochmal, nestet Virtualisierung. Woop, warum, macht er jetzt was? Warum macht
er jetzt einfach Bing auf ohne die Ergebnisse? Okay. Hallo? Ich würde da gerne was tippen
drinne jetzt. Denied. Oh jetzt gehts. Jetzt gehts. Moment, geh weg. Ah, Windows, please,
lass mich einfach was tippen. Clocks HD ist jetzt auch am Start. Twitch Prime, Dankeschön.
Serhietrant war auch vor 8 Minuten schon am Start. Hab ich denn schon vorgelesen? Ich
kann nicht. Wenn nicht, schade dir auch nix. Woop Lords Twitch. Ich fahr das Ding jetzt
gleich runter und starte es nochmal neu. Scheint sehr performant zu sein, die Sandbox. Naja,
man darf nicht vergessen, es ist Windows in Windows in Windows. Es ist Windows, es ist
VMWare, es ist Windows in VMWare und dann nestet Virtualisiert Sandbox. Felix Tegi,
subscribed. Dankeschön. Guys. Twitch, nestet Virtualisiert. Das ist Next Level, oder? Komplett
Next Level. Okay, dann wollen wir es nochmal ausprobieren. Soll ich es nochmal runterfahren
und ordentlich Shutdown machen und dann nochmal 4 Kerne und 8G geben. Jetzt noch Linux Subsystem
und X Server. Ja, ich hab ja schon vorgeschlagen. Da ist er. Der Stream Leute. Der Stream. Nested
Virtualisiert. Nested Virtualisiert. Unter Windows, in Windows, unter Windows. Ich mein,
es lässt sich nicht wirklich bedienen. Es hat ungefähr 0,2 FPS. So ungefähr ist es
so schnell, denke ich mal. Sogar der Taskmanager laggt. Hallo, Warforce 420. Sogar der. Ich
glaube, ich hab auf dem Rechner noch nie so hohe CPU-Auslastung gesehen, ey. Ich wusste
gar nicht, dass der Graph überhaupt komplett blau sein kann. Okay, wir fahren es ordentlich
runter. Ja, wir fahren es ordentlich. Was passiert eigentlich, wenn man das hier zuklickt? Einfach
zuklickt. Was passiert dann? Geht es dann kaputt? Ja, es freest. Es freest erstmal.
Windows. Es muss ja die Windows typischen Sachen beibehalten. Erstmal freezen. Ja,
ich bin mir sicher. Okay, richtig mal ordentlichen Shutdown, Leute. Ordentlichen Shutdown. Der
gibt die CPU gar nicht mehr her. Das ist jetzt. Auch wieder komische Musik, wo sie reden.
Geh weg. Okay, jetzt Shutdown. Bam. Simulation einer Simulation einer Simulation, ja. Wer
weiß? Vielleicht sind wir auch nur alle Bestandteile einer Simulation. Vielleicht gibt es uns alle
gar nicht. Vielleicht sind wir alle bloß in einer ausreichend komplex simulierten VM.
Okay, gucken wir mal, ob es jetzt funktioniert. Und die Frage der Fragen ist ja, sollten wir
es schaffen, man denkt mal an Sims 4, also an Sims 40, sollten wir es schaffen eine Simulation
unserer Welt zu erschaffen, stellen wir damit nicht quasi auch in Frage, ob es uns überhaupt
gibt. Weil wenn wir das schaffen, uns zu simulieren, wer sagt uns denn dann, dass uns nicht schon
längst jemand simuliert hat? Oh. Jetzt wird es ja esoterisch, ja. Das stimmt. Leute,
jetzt müssen wir uns mal belegen. Was meint ihr? Geht es jetzt oder geht es jetzt nicht?
Also wir haben es ja vorhin schon mal probiert. Sandbox ging, mehr RAM, mehr CPU, Sandbox
ging nicht. Jetzt ordentlich rebooted, wieder mehr RAM, mehr CPU, also quasi das, was es
eher besser machen würde. Ich tippe auch darauf, dass es nicht geht. Aber wir sehen
es ja schon gleich an der CPU-Auslastung, ob es geht oder nicht geht. Es geht nicht.
Es geht nicht. Tipp. Oder doch? Nein. Gebaidet. Ich frag mich, hat es hier was gemacht? Hat
sich das gerade bewegt? Gibt es seit heute eine neue Windows-Version? Nee, seit April
oder so. Das ist echt eine Wit, das ist echt Windows-Logik. Die verstehe ich nicht. Warum?
Warum geht das mit 6 GB RAM und 2 CPU-Kernen, aber es geht nicht mit 8 GB RAM und 4 CPU-Kernen?
Warum? Ich habe eine Idee. Wir machen jetzt Massive Play. Wir verarschen Windows jetzt.
Wir machen es jetzt anders. Wir machen jetzt nicht eine CPU mit 4 Kern, wir machen jetzt
2 CPUs mit 2 Kern. Jetzt ist vorbei. Jetzt kann es sich nicht mehr wehren. Und, und,
Moment Leute, und, und wir machen nicht 8 GB RAM, sondern, sondern, Achtung, wir machen
7996 MB RAM. Jetzt geht's, sag's euch Leute, jetzt geht's. Macht doch in QEMO, wir können
noch ein bisschen weiter Nested virtualisieren. Okay Leute, Predictions, geht oder geht nicht?
Na, 5050, ja. Mein Bauchgefühl sagt mir, und ihr wisst, ich hab da, da hab ich genug
davon, weil mein Bauchgefühl sagt, es geht. Geht anscheinend nicht. Wir wissen ja, das
ist direkt auf Anschlag mit CPU-Auslastung. Okay, ich geb's auf Leute, ich versteh die
Windows-Logik nicht. Ich glaube, man kann an dieser Stelle auch nicht von Windows-Logik
sprechen. Das ist eher Windows-Debating oder so. Was ist dein Ziel? Mein Ziel ist eigentlich
heute nur sinnlos zu streamen, weil ich Partner geworden bin. Und ich versuch gerade Windows
unter Windows zu virtualisieren und darin Windows zu betreiben. Und das funktioniert
allerdings lustigerweise nur mit 2 Kern und 6 GB RAM. Wenn ich 4 Kerne und 8 GB RAM gebe,
geht's auf einmal nicht mehr. Und wir haben alle keinen Plastenschimmer, woran das liegt.
Übrigens Leute, hab ich euch schon erzählt, dass wenn ihr einen Amazon Prime-Account habt,
dass ihr den kostenlos mit Twitch verbinden könnt und ihr bekommt dafür kostenlose zusätzliche
Lootboxen oder wie auch immer das genau heißt auf Twitch und ihr könnt den Streamer eurer
Wahl einmal im Monat kostenlos mit einem Sub unterstützen. So sieht's aus. Nur Leute mit
Big Prane machen das. Jetzt machen wir mal was ganz Abgedrehtes. 3 CPU-Kerne. 3 Kerne,
gibt's sonst nirgendswo. Aber unter Windows geht das wahrscheinlich. Probier mal noch
weniger Kerne, damit noch weniger Kerne geht's, das wissen wir ja. Wie sehen 3 Kerne im Taskmanager
aus? Gute Frage, kann man's angucken. So sehen 3 Kerne aus. 3. Ok, gucken wir mal, ob's
funktioniert. Die Musik geht fort. Das geht auch nicht. Ok, anscheinend ist Windows der
Meinung, das darf nur unter 2 CPU-Kernen funktionieren. Ich hab keine Ahnung warum. Weil. Äh ich mach
jetzt aus, ich mach jetzt Windows aus, hab jetzt kein Bock mehr. Also wir wissen, dass
es prinzipiell funktioniert, allerdings nur in schlechter Performance, weil Windows uns
nicht mehr Performance erlaubt. Oh, hab ich so viele Desktops auf. Ich blick nicht mehr
durch, zu viele Desktops. Würdest du einen Bann von Lootboxen befürworten, Belkin hatte
ja schon verboten. Ähm, also ich bin nicht dafür, ich bin selten dafür, irgendwas komplett
zu verbieten. Aber ich finde im Falle Lootboxen, also ich hab kein Problem mit das Lootboxen
im Game sind, es ist die Frage immer, wie's eingesetzt wird. Und vor allem bei Mobile
Games und jetzt natürlich auch neuerdings, ich mein Battlefront war jetzt ein prominentes
Beispiel für, dient es ja im Prinzip dazu, die Leute zu verarschen. Ja, mit extra langen
Grindzeiten im Hauptgame, teilweise mit ultra kleiner Loot-Chance von irgendeinem Held
oder von irgendwas. Ich find's an sich gar nicht so schlimm, wenn's Lootboxen gibt,
aber man sollte, es muss klar erkenntlich sein, ähm, erstens natürlich was man raus
bekommen kann und wie wahrscheinlich das Ganze ist, dass man was bekommt. Und was ich
auch prinzipiell nicht schlecht finden würde, wenn Spiele, die quasi so nen Glücksfaktor
drinnen haben, erst ab einem gewissen Alter freigegeben werden, egal wie der Inhalt vom
Spiel ist. Allerdings ist halt die Frage, ob das überhaupt irgendwelche Auswirkungen
hat, ne. Weil ganz ehrlich, wer von uns hat bis 18 gewartet, um Spiele mit 18 zu spielen?
Oder wer hat, wer von uns hat gewartet, bis 16 zum Spiele ab 16 zu spielen?
Max Nutztmann Jaro mit i3 WM, ja da hat der Nightbot Recht. Was sagt eigentlich mal Pepega
Board, was wir noch für Fragen haben? Wir haben viele Fragen, aber vom letzten Streben
nach. Oh, ich habe meine, Leute, ich noob, ich hab meinen Linux VM ausgeschaltet. Jetzt
hat das Pepega Board nicht mal mitgeloggt, was der Chat gefragt hat. Also falls ihr in
den letzten 20 Minuten irgendwas gefragt habt im Chat, und ich hab's noch nicht beantwortet,
dann müsst ihr das gleich, wenn ich das Board gestartet habe, nochmal posten. Moment, aber
jetzt noch nicht, jetzt noch nicht. Ja, richtiger Fail, Leute, gleich Disabo, gleich Disabo.
So, jetzt ist wieder gestartet, jetzt könnt ihr noch mal fragen, falls es noch was gab.
Okay, das hatten wir, das hatten wir auch. Und löschen wir mal von unten.
So viele Nachrichten. Mein Tool ist irgendwie kaputt, das zeigt nicht alles an. Ach, ich
glaube, ich weiß woran das liegt. Ich glaube, ich habe ein Limit von nur 50, nur ein Limit
von nur 50 Fragen drinne. Fail. Programming Noob. Wirkt euch das mal an, wie viele Sachen
da eigentlich drinne sind. Womit wird die Sandbox eigentlich virtualisiert? Ich denke
mal, das Hyper-V. Was hast du dir bei Electro Boom anguckt? Ich
habe nur den Channel gezeigt, weil irgendjemand vorhin gefragt hat, was gute Technik-Channels
sind. Habe ich zwei Channels gezeigt, dabei einer davon. Den gucke ich halt wirklich
gern, der ist sehr nice. Also, wie viele Fragen hier drin sind. Also, das ist von vor 5 Streams
oder so, weil ich wieder nicht gelöscht habe. Der grillt sich doch immer selber, ja genau.
Willst du auch Gaming-Streams machen? Ja klar, spätestens, wenn Bad Company 3 rauskommt,
geht es wieder ab. Gibt es eigentlich was Neues? Gibt es was Neues? Nein, gibt es nicht.
Ich glaube, im deutschen Bereich bist du aber auch der kompetenteste und interessanteste
Streamer. Ich habe kein passendes Emote dafür. Würde ich das Herzchen-Emote machen. Die
Kompetenz ist ja eh nur gefaked, ich hoffe, das ist euch allen klar. Ich tue eigentlich
nur so, als kenne ich mich damit aus. Denkst du eher an Tutorials oder News-Gelaber für
YouTube? News-Gelaber eigentlich eher nicht. Außer, dass es wirklich bedeutsam ist. Ja,
so das kann man beliebig weiterspinnen. Oh Patrick, ja ich weiß, was du meinst, wie
hieß das Ding dann? Das ist so ultra low-level Zeug gewesen, also quasi fast noch unter USB,
also wo du quasi auch Tastatureingaben faken kannst, wo man nicht mal erkennt, dass die
Taste abgedrückt wurde. Das hast du bestimmt noch im Discount, ich weiß gerade nicht mehr,
wie das Ding hieß. Hast du schon was geplant, wann der Stream morgen startet? Na ja, morgen
ist Samstag, wahrscheinlich Mittag oder Nachmittag. Der ohne Kohle, tatsächlich, das gibt echt
Leute, die das geguckt haben, nice. Dabei, ich hätte mir über das Video viel mehr Gedanken
machen müssen, da gibt es noch viel mehr coole Sachen. Übrigens, die Idee des Tages
hat derjenige gewonnen, also nicht, dass es dafür was zu gewinnen gibt, aber die beste
Idee heute im Stream fand ich diese Sache mit dem Keks, den man füttern muss unten
im Stream. Das können wir wirklich selbst programmieren, sowas, da muss ich allerdings
noch einen Grafik-FX-Mensch finden, der die passenden Kekse machen kann dafür. Na ja,
die brauchen einen halb zerkrümelten Keks, den löchrigen Keks, den Keks, der gut drauf
ist. Wozu brauchst du denn eine mini WLAN-Kamera? Kannst du gute Access Points empfehlen? Ja,
den Pro Access Point von Ubiquiti ist ziemlich gut. Hat zwar auch seine Macken, vor allem,
dass man diesen komischen Controller für braucht, das kann ein ordentliches Webinterface
haben, aber der reine Access Point davon ist ziemlich gut. Flo690, ich habe den Reboot-Clip
mal einem auf der Arbeit gezeigt, der konnte sich das Ganze auch nicht erklären. Das Einzige,
was wir uns zusammenreimen konnten, ist, dass diejenigen, die das Image gebaut haben, in
der History-Reboot drin stehen hatten und ich es irgendwie geschafft habe, mit meinem Rumgeklick
und gemachte vorher noch einen Pfeil nach oben, eine Escape-Sequenz oder so drin zu haben,
keine Ahnung, kann sich keiner erklären. Warten wir schon?
Wie viele kannst du eigentlich haben? Ich weiß es nicht. Ich habe auch keine Ahnung,
wo ich Sub-Batches und irgendwas hochlade. Ich muss erstmal gucken. Weißt du oder jemand
im Chat, wie man eine Weile schlafen kann mit einem Tastendruckband in Steuerung C, also
Linux-Shell. Und halte mal Steuerung C ein bisschen gedrückt, das braucht man kurz.
Kannst du mir eine LXC-Frage mal antworten? Klar, schieß los.
Mal eine Frage zur LXC. Kann man Container beim Startup automatisch einen anderen DNS-Server
in der Resolve-Conf setzen? Derzeit nimmt er den vom Haus, der ist aber nicht vom Container
erreichbar. Du kannst mit LXD, also mit diesem Ubuntu Zeug, kannst du Parameter für jede
VM überschreiben. Muss man nachgucken, ob es die Möglichkeit gibt, den DNS zu überschreiben,
das weiß ich nicht. Also nicht aus dem Kopf. Ja, das könnte ich sein, genau. Ja, das war
das. Wie viele Subs hast du schon? Ich weiß noch nicht mal, wo der Sub-Counter steht, da
würde ich nachgucken. Aber ich tippe mal so auf 35 oder so. Also huge.
Alles, wir haben alles.
Xe-Marsel, nice, Dankeschön, Twitch Prime. Poggers. Okay Leute, es ist 21.20, ich
habe noch nichts gefuttert heute Abend. Ich werde erst mal was essen gehen. Wir gucken
mal, wen wir hosten können. Es war schön, dass ihr spontan wieder alle mit am Start
gewesen seid. Das war jetzt ja relativ spontan das Ganze. Eigentlich wollte ich erst morgen
mit dem Staubsauger streamen. Morgen, Nachmittag, Mittag, Nachmittag, Abend, so, irgendwie,
in dem Dreh, ich weiß noch nicht genau, wann es losgeht, flashen wir meinen Staubsauger
mit neuer Firmware und gucken, wie das Ganze funktioniert. Wann geht es los? Ich weiß
noch nicht ganz genau. Ich denke mal, wahrscheinlich so 16 Uhr oder sowas. Flashen wir den Staubsauger
und gucken mal, was die neue Firmware taugt. Ich habe mir schon kurz den Changelog angeguckt,
es sind ein paar gute Sachen dabei. So, jetzt schauen wir mal, wen wir hosten können.
Inside das Universum. Was ist das? Das ist Universum, der meint das Wort wörtlich. Das
ist Big Brain Stream. Java, den haben wir letztens gehostet schon. Let's develop Unity
Creator Kit. Der hat schon mal einen niedlichen Avatar, das gefällt mir. Entspanntes Fivum.
Fivum, was ist das? Was ist das für eine Sprache? Ich würde sagen, auf den ersten
Blick hätte ich gesagt, JavaScript, aber dann doch wieder nicht. Was ist das für eine
Sprache? Ist das Lua? Nee. Ah, das ist die GTA Mode. Was ist das für eine Sprache? Könnte
doch Lua sein, oder? Wenn es ein Modtool ist, dann ist Lua gar nicht so unwahrscheinlich.
Okay, wir sind uns einig, es muss Lua sein. Android Flutter App. Spring Boot. Java. 3D
Drucker Schach. Dieser Stream, der ist fast 24-7 gefühlt online. Jedes Mal, wenn wir
gucken, ist der online und der hat im Stream die Kamera von seinem 3D Drucker. Was macht
der hier? Ist der nackig? Ähm, den wollen wir hosten. Sagt
mir, ich muss ehrlich sagen, spontan sagt mir gar nichts so richtig zu. Schau mal bei
Just Chatting. Just Chatting auf Deutsch. Grillz, Grillz. Grillz. So viele Grillz mittlerweile.
Huge. Sollten wir gerade explizit sagen, nein, machen wir nicht. Guck einfach, wenn man
so hosten kann, ob irgendjemand dabei ist, den ich vielleicht kenne, oder irgendetwas,
was mich so direkt anspricht vom Titel her. Aber krass, wie viele Mädels mittlerweile
streamen, oder? Und nicht eine, nicht eine Boobcam, oder? Sehe ich das richtig? Sachen
gibt's eher. Da war PC-Build? 18 plus. PC-Build. Warum ist das 18 plus? Okay, wo ist, wo ist
der Dude? Muss ich mir jetzt mal angucken kurz. Nicht, dass der wieder ohne Hose wieder
andere da im Stream setzt. Sind das zwei? Das sind zwei, oder? Dual Build. PC, PC-Building-
Simulator. Stimmt, warum ist er vier Stunden am bauen? Ah fuck. What why? Ah vier Stunden
mindersinstallation. Kann das sein, dass er sich einfach nur angeguckt hat? Nee. Ach
Leute, keine Ahnung, wen ich hosten soll. Sagt mir heute, sagt mir heute überhaupt
nichts zu. Wir machen dann jetzt einfach so Schluss. Morgen sehen wir uns mit dem Staubsauger,
der geflasht wird. Und ich guck jetzt mal, ob ich noch irgendwelche Subs verpasst hab.
Nope. Also Leute, danke für die ganzen Subs heute, auch für die ganzen Follows und dass
hier wieder so viele Leute wart, die einfach nur sinnlos beim Schwätzen zugeguckt haben.
Wir sehen uns morgen, machts gut. See you.